Hello everybody!
That's wonderful.
Wait, are you still on your phone?
Yeah!
I thought you were gonna get out your...
Where are you still?
Guys, I was listening to Gumi eat her, chopping her
artichokes.
And now her stomach hurts because she ate too many
She ate too many artichokes.
Two artichokes.
I had I had an artichoke cam while we were I was waiting
Okay guys several disargument with most me guys Is artichoke
a food or a side dish a garnish a Artichokes a fucking a A
dressing I don't think artichoke is a food you don't just
eat you don't just eat ate artichoke you have other things
with the artichoke she just ate an artichoke for like dinner
last night she's like what do you what do you she just ate i
was like what you just ate an artichoke and she's like yeah
it's ate an artichoke it's like her favorite thing i was
like that's that's not food that's not that's not food you
can't just eat an artichoke and then we had like a debate
about whether or not vegetables are considered food and
sorry for all the vegetarians and vegans out there I'm
telling you artichoke is do you know what a garnish or a
dressing is yes I know what it is but like artichoke is like
it's just artichoke you know it's just an artichoke.
You tell me, you tell me what your definition of a garnish
and or a dressing is.
It's like a side thing.
Like, you know, you put it on top of real food.
You're pissing me off.
What do you mean?
A side thing.
You don't just eat artichoke.
You don't just order.
Okay, do you go to a restaurant and just order one
artichoke?
Like, yes, you can get...
Sometimes?
You really?
Yeah, is it a main dish or a side dish?
But hold on, I got my artichokes from Costco and they're
really big.
That's not a restaurant!
What are you saying?
You're like, I was like, do you go to a restaurant and
like...
I said yes!
Then you went, I go to Costco.
I was telling you that I went to Costco and got these Really
big artichokes.
That's why it's not just a side dish to me.
Yeah, but you chop off the big artichoke and then make it
into small things.
So you can just have... You don't just eat an artichoke as a
main dish.
We just don't.
What do you mean chop up the artichoke?
Do you know how to eat an artichoke?
Yeah, you chop... I literally saw you.
You were like live streaming yourself chopping artichokes
for me.
What the fuck do you mean?
You have to cut the top of the leaf.
off it's it's an artichoke you can't just eat an artichoke
you can't it's it's impossible what do you mean it's
impossible by the way I never got your what do you mean are
you just too busy chopping I hate chopping artichokes okay
let me invite you again I invited you I'm I'm still not
getting it.
Wait, what?
Is it because I didn't click play on mine phrase?
Yeah, thank you.
Wait, wait, what?
Wait, what?
Wait, no, that's not right.
Okay.
You got it?
Nope.
My sound guy was like, Gumi's volume is good despite her
passion for art.
I need to talk to your sound guy.
Adam did a great chat.
All right, I'm gonna make a poll.
I'm gonna make a poll.
I'm gonna make a poll
Is artichokes are artichokes a mini dish?
Guys, I need you guys to actually vote with your heart and
don't vote because you you want to fuck with me What do you
mean they always vote with their heart?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I need
to vote with their heart like like would you eat with my
heart?
Would you eat a artichoke as your main dish like okay
Vegetarians don't just eat artichokes they eat salads.
They can have salads and like other shit They don't just be
like halo stare.
I would just want an artichoke.
They don't say that They don't say I might not be a
vegetarian, but I won't be like hello Can I just have an
artichoke for dinner?
Like I would not say that it is like a side and an appetizer
exactly look 70% people agree with me that it's not a me I
never said it was a main dish this was our entire argument
this was our entire argument I was like do you see the art
show and you know what's that you called it a dressing or
garnish no you're dressing dressing garnish side I said it
can't be all three it cannot be all three no I said dressing
garnish or side and And you were like, you were like, no,
it's I ate, I just eat the artichoke.
It's like, that is not that.
You can't do that.
You can't just eat an artichoke as a main dish.
Also, I sent you another invite.
I can do that.
I just, I just sent you another invite.
I'm not getting it.
Then you are what's wrong with this.
I said it was my main dish.
Not everyone's main dish.
But my main dish.
So you're a freak then.
But do you know what?
I'll even send you a photo of my artichoke from last night.
I was...
I was eating that shit.
You're like, oh, I think I got my tummy hurt because it was
from the artichoke.
Yeah?
Yeah, I said that.
Who else?
What?
No, it's because I ate two artichokes yesterday.
Oh my god, I hold two.
I wonder...
You can't just get a stomach ache because you...
Oh my god.
It's like, yeah, I had two eggs today.
That's why my tummy hurt.
Like, what?
logic what is that logic no I'm saying this because of the
fiber the fiber it's gonna make me need a
pool holy shit those are giant artichos I told you what the
fuck look at size comparison what that you're freaking
sent me a picture of her artichoke.
Go ahead, I don't care.
And I was like, what the fuck is this?
What the fuck is this giant ass artichoke?
What kind of, what the fuck, were they grown in a lab or
some shit?
What is this fucking artichoke that I'm looking at?
Alright guys, I'm gonna try not to show Gumi's thighs as
well.
Dude, I had to take the photo like that because my kids
keeper was messed up whoops accidentally i accidentally okay
i sized myself bigger just for comparison with the artichoke
which it was sort of an accident but what do you mean by
comparison like look oh my god that's a john ass artichoke
no wonder your tummy hurt
holy fuck also give me a sec guys i need to resize myself
i'm way close to the screen what the is that that's an
artichoke that's what oh dang what the fuck is that what the
fuck is that look if people in my chat are like what the
fuck is that
saying those are giant artichokes this is true and that's
why it was a main dish to me because it was so huge.
But don't why don't you just cut it up?
Cut it up.
It doesn't change the way you eat it.
Someone was like that thing belongs to the wilderness, not
the table.
That looks like a dead space baby genetically modified
artichoke.
No, do you know what?
You're right?
Because they are fucking huge.
And my mom bought me them because she's like, look how big
these artichokes are.
And I know you love artichokes.
I was like, you're supposed to take it apart.
What the fuck?
Well, you're not even eating artichokes, right?
No, you haven't.
That's what I've been saying.
Because you called it...
Garnish, dude.
Garnish is like putting like tiny parsley on top.
Well, like, yeah, I mean, you can still put that on top.
It's just gonna be the whole thing.
Bro, accept my fucking input.
I said you were like three.
I'm telling you, it's not working.
We start your game.
I did.
Oh, wait, no, I didn't.
I know you did it because you were too busy talking about my
artichoke.
Look, it's not.
Look that.
It was important.
It was a very important conversation.
You wouldn't understand.
You're out here fucking stuffing yourself in artichokes.
Can we talk about our wording?
Can we talk about how we phrasing?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm not going to change my wording.
What are you talking about?
What the fuck?
I'm not going to cheat.
Okay.
All right.
Let me invite you again.
Play online.
I'm connecting okay I'm literally staring at the game I'm
staring at you an invite I got it I got it it wasn't my
fault you you literally just restarted you because you
restarted too right so we'll never know whose fault it is I
didn't restart because we'll never know no you restarted
right no we'll never know whose fault it is guys we'll never
know all right this is me We're getting a divorce.
I don't know if you guys noticed, but we're...
Guys, I don't know if you guys noticed, but we might be
getting a divorce.
We might be.
Gumi, are you alive?
Gumi?
Oh, I think she's dead.
Guys.
Sorry, I was talking about my heart to choke.
Are you choking on your heart?
to cut up the artichoke.
That's not how you eat it.
Yes, you can.
Just cut it up.
You're fucking choking.
I wasn't choking.
I was getting my controller.
You just said you were choking on an artichoke.
You're making shit up.
No, no, no.
I'm pretty chat.
Chat, did I hear it correctly?
She said she was choking on the artichoke.
She has so many toes.
All right, what were you supposed to do here?
Oh, we had the car All right, I call dibs on the car No, no,
it's because you were driving.
I'm a better driver It's time for a new friend because I'm
the wife.
She'd outgrown the elephant.
She did.
It's not because of whatever you are It's just that you as a
person I just If your personality is just our worst driver,
nothing else.
That's crazy.
That's a crazy line.
Oh, I see.
Yay!
Okay.
What the fuck was that?
Alright, you pulled too hard!
Stop pulling it!
What was that?
I thought!
Oh my god.
Okay.
See, this is it.
This is why.
This is why we're getting in the forest.
Oh, we did it!
Yay, it was just for an achievement.
Let's leave.
I want to ride in the car.
Alright, alright.
Fine, fine, fine.
What the fuck?
You won't ride in the car?
Is that what you want?
Why is it going on?
Is that what you...
Whoa.
Is that what you want?
Yay!
Wait, hold it.
Where are we going?
Wait, can I just send you through that hole?
You see that hole?
Hold on.
Aim it.
Aim it?
Okay.
Well, there's an invisible wall there.
I'm gonna get out of here Alright, I got this Go Go wife Go
What the fuck are you What?
What have you been waiting?
Go wife Go Is that not how you talk to Talk to wife?
Hey, you know how I said Wait right there Sorry, I can't
read.
What do you mean you can't read?
I can't read.
I'm sorry.
What?
Oh, okay, you have to do that again.
I thought it would be like a easy thing.
All right.
What?
Did you just miss?
It's live!
Slid off!
How do you miss?
It's literally right in front of you.
I said it slid off.
Why?
How you miss?
Wife.
Oh my god, look, it's Woody.
How did you miss wife?
Wait, how do you...
Oh.
What the fuck did I just see?
Okay.
Nothing.
You didn't hit the flag!
You were supposed to hit the flag with Mario!
I was?
Yeah, now we can't get over.
I didn't grow up with Mario.
No, that's just an achievement.
Now we can't get over.
There's a hole right here.
The hole is the goal.
Let's get over to the secret side.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Blame the husband.
Yeah, yeah.
It's never your fault.
Wait, what's this?
There's, like, these green things.
What is that?
No, no.
Wait, I think math is next!
I'm pretty sure this is the math area.
Wait, was this useless?
Was this...
Was this a useless thing to do?
You fucking bitch!
I'm catching up!
I'm right here now!
Hey, what's going on?
I'm catching up!
What's going on?
Hey!
Ah!
Oh shit!
Okay, you're back here with me!
Yeah!
Hey!
Oh fuck, okay!
Wait, I figured this out.
You can't do this without me, you know that.
It's fine, I'm here now.
What do we do?
Oh, oh, we have to press this at the same time.
Wait, but who's the...
Who's the...
Oh, because I have to go.
Oh.
Yeah, you go.
And then you...
And then you press...
Oh, mouse!
That's not a mouse.
That's a dog.
Look at the fucking...
That's a충.
Look at the teeth.
Okay, you have ?
Open the mouse!
Oh, wait, did you say open the mouse?
Mouse, mouse!
Mouse!
Boor!
B from there!
Babel, bear!
Yeah, that wasn't so difficult, was it?
Okay, you can screen cheat, by the way.
Oh, my god, you're pro- Wait, wait, I said you- Why did you
do that?
I am against screen peeking.
Oh, yeah, now you're against screen peeking.
Yeah, now you are.
What happened?
I need you to tell me what next.
Dog.
Lion, lion, lion, lion, lion Lion, lion Sheep Sheep Ba Frog
Ribbit, ribbit, ribbit Lion, lion, lion
I hate that we have to work together Open it
It's a cute egg
Yeah, my beautiful wife.
Hello.
What took you so long?
My beautiful wife.
Who I love very much.
I fucking hate my husband.
Whoa!
I worked so hard to put food on the table.
And that's what you say?
I'm the engineer, so...
Yeah, and I'm a farmer.
It looks like we have to solve it.
What's the other night?
This will be easy.
Wait, 6 plus 5?
6.
Oh, 6 plus 3.
Yeah.
See?
Simple.
Quick maths.
Yay.
Get off of 6, you wish.
6 plus 1 makes 16.
You need to move on 8!
6 plus 1 is to make 16.
6 plus 1!
Get on 8!
Well, this is embarrassing.
You suck at math.
6 and 1.
What?
Mix what?
What's Mix 8?
Two!
That's my drink.
It's two.
Okay, I'll go here now.
We can be six together.
You said this would be easy, man.
You're pissing me.
Get on three right now.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Oh, I got six!
Yeah!
Oh, what's this?
A memory.
Remember!
Okay, there's two cherries here.
Okay, now they're not there anymore.
They're not there.
Orange.
Oh, strawberry.
I already forgot half of these.
Oh, strawberry!
Here!
And then... Banana!
Cherry's a...
Oh, here, here, here!
No!
I actually... No!
Okay, that wasn't a cherry.
Where is the egg plant?
Cherry!
Okay, we had two.
No, that's the egg plant.
Oh, thank God I was actually wearing the orange one.
Oh, more math.
That's not math.
It's numbers.
Oh, I can do that.
Wait, do you have...
Can it just be you moving?
Push it!
Oh, I go up.
I go up.
And then you go...
It's this way.
It's right.
And then 7 is up.
What do you mean it's right?
I'm literally going right.
It's up.
It's down.
Okay.
Whoa.
Why are you going to 11?
What do you mean?
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to.
to navigate, woman.
Try to do what, woman?
Alright, 60.
Hey, it's right inside.
What are you doing?
I'm literally going right.
No, you're not.
I feel the resistance.
Wait, where's the 20?
Is it above me?
Oh, where the fuck did the 20 go?
Where was the 20?
Right here.
Oh, that's how that was the 26.
26.
That looked like a 26.
I couldn't tell.
Okay, you can move.
All right.
I thought that was a 26.
The zero was like, was like scratched off.
Okay.
10, 11, 12.
This is like, this does not look great.
weekend ugly.
That's your fault.
Why is it my fault?
It takes two to tangle.
Wow, how did we fuck that up?
You're taking too long.
How?
It took too long.
I am really moving so fucking fast.
Alright, alright.
I am going so fast.
I'm pushing the crosshair.
Okay, here we go.
Nine.
Where are you going?
Why do you keep forgetting 10 why why what did 10 do to you
how do we know it's me how do we know it's me it takes two
how it literally says it takes two how do you know it's my
fault because you keep going lower than we need to you don't
know that as long as i get it in that's all that matter
how how did that happen like i literally pressed it i
literally pressed it i swear to guy i swear that was not my
fault that was not my fault where are you going
okay i am it's just the drawing is supposed to be like this
okay what 14 it was born this way 15 and then 16 7 see like
why does it do that we went to 17 that is not our fault i
literally went to 17 It's a 17!
I don't know what's wrong.
That wasn't even...
That's not even my fault at that point.
Okay.
I don't know why we can't get past 16.
I don't know why.
Why?
Why can't we do this?
I can't understand.
Hey, dude.
What's your sense on your mouth?
No, it's not my fault.
It is not my fault.
All right, I'm going to let you move, okay?
There.
See, look.
I'm letting you do most of the heavy lifting now.
Where are you going?
It's 11.
Okay.
I can't move because of you!
What do you mean?
I can't move either!
Okay.
14.
Alright, 15.
Alright, 16.
See!
That's not even us!
That's not!
That's not even me!
That is not even me!
Xbox, Google How to do?
Oh!
It's not even me.
I swear I swear to God.
Help.
I'm all the way on the side now.
How we stuck on this one of all fucking problems.
Change your mouse DPI.
What do you mean?
My fucking DPI is high enough!
Okay, let's see.
Change into options.
Change into the options.
Okay, which one?
Which one?
Am I Cody?
I'm Cody, right?
You're Cody.
Yeah, okay.
Horizontal.
Wait, which one?
Do I change it to... Okay, I'm changing this to...
It's not me!
I swear to God!
Oh, wait.
Back.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
Okay, we should restart this, though.
We should restart it because I was drawing a line.
Look, see?
Look at us.
Look at us go.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, it's very smooth.
Uh-huh.
How the fuck did we progress to 6 out of 16?
I don't understand how we did that Maybe we go left Maybe we
go left instead of up
Okay And then Oh my god we do we have to go left Oh my god
we're making it We're doing it go down Go down oh my god we
progressed We got past 16 This is so easy now Go up I am 24
What the fuck is this stupid drawing?
It's a cat?
How the fuck did it make a cat?
That's one ugly ass cat.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
How the fuck did we make a cat?
Look
at the mouse.
Oh, that's us.
Oh, these games.
I had one of these as a kid.
Mousetrap?
No, like the, the, oh my god, it's way too high now.
The sensitivity, give me a sec.
I'm going back down next time.
like back down this is way too high okay nice all right i'm
good tell me we have to play with every toy how do we do
this i don't think those those nails matter matter i'm ready
i'm ready of course where are you doing she beats me every
time looks like it's interesting press the button to let the
mouse out wait we do like here How?
I don't think we let it out now.
I think we have to do these first.
Like the ones in front of us first.
We have to do this because there's an objective point here.
Am I green or blue?
You're green.
Oh, I'm green.
Alright.
How do we do this?
Oh, we had to stand on there.
We had to stand.
Yeah, and then we go up.
Oh my god, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
We're working together as a couple.
Our divorce is not a mess.
Our marriage is salvageable.
Barely.
Hey, hey, that's...
There's still hope.
That means there's still hope.
Yay!
See?
We can fix our marriage.
Look at us go.
Even if it's not fixable, it wasn't my fault that this
marriage died.
What?
I'm just saying I think I was the better parent Yeah, okay
No That could have been a child What What if that ball right
there is our child And this is a metaphor Of how we take
care of it I'm not doing it already out there.
I know it's all about control, man.
I did it.
Yay.
Where is the ball?
Where the fuck is the ball?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, now we push the thing.
Here, go, go, get the cheese.
There's the cheese, mousy.
There it is.
Are you happy now?
Oh, that's torture.
You see?
Told you the mice are friendly.
That's actually torture.
What's this?
Oh!
What the heck?
Just move up.
And then, we have to make sure we jump fast enough.
But that's okay, because we're gamers.
Ow.
Wait up!
It's okay, we did it.
We're gamers.
All right, I'm holding it.
What do we do here?
Can we just jump on it?
Where do we go?
There's a rope thingy up there.
There is?
How do we get up there?
Wait, am I not supposed to wall jump?
I don't know.
Are we?
Oh!
Wait, what happened?
How do... How?
I'm so confused.
Okay, I'm coming back.
Let's...
You're...
Oh, like, how do we, like...
Because, like, I can't do that, though.
Oh!
It's the side!
Yeah.
That's why I'm the gamer.
I figured it out.
I literally did that earlier.
I did it.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm a genius husband.
Any women would be lucky to have me.
What?
Really?
What is this?
Oh, it's the whoopee cushion.
Other one, other one, other one, other one.
Alright.
Yay!
And then...
I pumped it.
Wait, then what?
What are you doing?
Oh, okay.
I pumped it.
I think you're supposed to land the other one.
Yeah.
I think you're supposed to...
Here, and then...
There, and then- Oh, what?
Upies!
Didn't you land on there?
Okay.
Wait, what?
Can you not get there?
Wait, do you have to launch that one?
I don't know.
What was that for?
What?
Oh!
Do we both have to?
Huh?
I don't think it's possible.
It says pull my finger, though.
Oh, like, what does that mean?
I'm letting you go up?
Oh, we both need to be on it.
And what?
How did you...
What?
How do I get there?
I can't get there.
Smash in and run over?
No, because there's a timer.
Oh, maybe?
Oh, maybe.
No?
Let's see.
Yeah, no, there's no...
There's, like, a delay.
Oh.
Yeah, there's a delay.
oh wait wait wait wait hold on does pulling the finger make
that spin no why is it spinning why is it pulled what's
activated oh wait there's a thing over there do you see that
there was a thing on top but is that the what oh yeah
there's a thing on top that's spinning there's a hook i see
it there's a hook oh wait pull it pull it Go here go here.
There's a hook that shows up.
You'll see it And then you hang in there and then there's a
hook that shows up.
I see it now Wait, see that hook?
There's a hook right there.
No, I knew about the hook.
I tried to go for it earlier Yeah, but I think you're
supposed to drop down.
Wait, why do you keep- why do you- I didn't drop down?
We figured it out together I
Yay!
We did it together!
Because we are a lovely couple who's going through a rough
path.
Get on the dog.
Yeah, I'm where?
Oh!
There you go.
I'm on it.
Yay!
I pulled the thing.
Okay, I'm gonna head over.
Jumping in.
Alright, I'm on it.
We're a lovely couple.
I know.
Everybody thinks so.
We think we're made for each other.
God, I hope they never say that again.
We just have some little differences.
Look, that's why...
We should go to, like, therapy instead.
You know, instead of that.
We should go to couples counseling.
Reddit.
Am I the asshole?
I hate my wife.
But it's her fault.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What's that?
Air dash.
What the fuck does that mean?
We just...
Where's the prize?
Give me something useful.
Just keep doing it?
Maybe we have to keep doing it.
What's this?
Air dash again.
That's it?
It has to be more, right?
Is that really it?
That's crotch.
Oh my god, Dwan!
Is that crotch?
Oh, crotch!
I thought this is crotch.
I was like, what the fuck is crotch?
Yay!
Wait, we can swim?
What does this do?
Oh, we can swim!
Yay!
Oh!
swim.
Don't swim.
I drank this pipe all the way.
I don't know what it did, though.
Don't swim.
Swimming was always a mistake.
Why did those balls fall?
No, the balls were always there.
Oh, wait to do this other one.
There's one over here.
I got it.
I'm pulling the lever.
Am I pulling it the right way?
It's spinning so it should be the right way.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Teamwork.
Yay.
All right.
So we're going to go to couples counseling to fix our
issues.
Oh my god, look.
Oh, it's an Etch-a-Sketch.
I used to own one of these.
Me too.
What are we trying to draw?
Yeah, but what about creativity being stifled and all that?
Just can't do much with two knives.
I don't know, but I think we just made like a Marvel logo.
Now we just made Texas or something.
It's beautiful.
What the fuck are you making?
It looks like Stonehenge.
I stopped touching the thing.
Wait, was that it?
It wasn't like an actual game?
Wait, we can make...
Shut up!
I was gonna say!
What was I gonna say?
I don't know.
I just wanted to...
What was I gonna say?
I couldn't even think I was gonna say something.
What was it?
Oh, I'm gonna put the last coin in.
Wait, I'm doing the teeth.
Oh my god!
Yay!
Oh, it's so cute!
Oh, come over here.
You're so hot.
But I smashed this.
I did five and I was okay.
It's your turn.
Okay.
Your turn.
Nice.
What is this?
I was like a little bar kid is like 10 or some shit.
She should not be reading this.
Dude, I think these were her old toys.
Oh my god, game, game, game, game.
Oh, what's this?
It's a bat time?
Swing a bat.
This will be a piece of cake.
Let me do this.
Oh.
It took my ball forever to get back.
You just didn't hit it hard enough.
Oh god.
I'm missing now.
Please.
Look at that.
I'm going so fast.
Oh.
It's because like if you...
No!
Fuck!
No, no, no, no, no.
It's because if you miss, if you miss, it goes slower.
So you have to like have it.
a heavy rhythm.
Because the more you go, the faster you are.
I keep sending it backwards.
You hit it at the right angle.
It's alright.
That's why I'm mansplaining.
Oh, thank you, husband.
Oh, husband, we can't afford rent.
You keep buying too many battle pass.
I did it, wife.
Are you proud of me?
Husband, please stop buying battle pass.
We can't afford Didn't know.
But I gotta get my John Cena.
You wouldn't understand.
You wouldn't understand me.
Husband, please.
Okay.
But what about...
Who the fuck we bought fidget spinners?
Your baby ain't hurt too much.
I only spin, you know.
In the real world, yes.
Oh.
Whoa.
You're not a- Yeah, that's right.
Gumi's not a gamer if she's trying to restrict my Fortnite
passes.
I spent- we need to eat.
Whoa!
We could eat or...
Or...
Or we could have the John Cena skin.
Ooh!
Wait, what?
I landed on the...
Where do I have to go?
Oh, over there.
Okay.
Where else would we go?
I don't know!
Oh!
What?!
Okay.
That was weird.
Alright, I got it.
Woohoo!
I'm twisting the knob.
That's my special move.
What?
Spin it away, baby!
Why did you use that?
What are they twisting us to?
Why did you ewe that?
I don't know, actually.
What did it do?
Where does that open up?
Oh, it's over to the- Oh, isn't it here?
There's a- it's over here.
Oh yeah, do that one.
Yeah, there's one here.
All right, twisting the knob.
Your favorite move.
I'm gonna need you to stop talking once and for all.
I don't understand!
What did I say?
What the fuck did I say?
Testing these knobs should turn this pipe off.
Well, we have to find a yellow pipe.
Oh, I found it.
It's over behind us.
We already did the yellow pipe.
No, it didn't.
We did the purple pipe.
There's a yellow pipe right here.
There, I got you.
What was the purple pipe for then?
I don't know.
I mean, free up the one...
It's free up the red.
Oh, I see.
Nice, okay.
Then we head over there.
Oh my god, Doki Carry!
I know!
I'm carrying!
I need a break from last week.
What?
Let's go to the beach, beach!
Yay!
Jaja!
We bought our daughter a bouncy castle?
You didn't get one?
We bought her a bouncy... Is this why we're having money
issues?
Hey, I make the money, you're the one that's in charge of
home and you've been spending it.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
There's no way I bought this for her.
I'm too busy fucking farming.
How the fuck?
It can't be, I think it has to be you.
You're trying to compensate for your lack of...
Like what?
Lack of presents in our daughter's life.
You're trying to, so, you're trying way too hard to
compensate for this.
Yeah, okay, bud.
You're like, you're like the one where you're like at work
like 20 hours over the 24 hours, and then you come home with
like a bouncy castle.
Wait, I had a bouncy castle when I was a kid.
Okay, don't think too hard about that.
Don't think too hard about that.
You mean it?
I'm just talking about this game.
It's not related to anything in real life.
It's just...
It's just about...
It's just this game.
I'm just talking about a hypothetical in this game.
You mean it, really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, how do I...
Hello?
Oh, I have to smash it.
Yay!
I hate this guy.
Me too.
Oh, no!
Oh, here we go again.
My plan is working!
You like each other.
This guy fucking sucks.
There are more things to learn and new challenges to
overcome.
Let's keep on going.
We got a relationship to fix.
Woohoo!
What the hell?
Oh god, that's trippy.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like that.
Oh.
Hello, kaleidoscopes.
Oh, this is... Oh!
I don't like this!
Oh my god!
This is way too fucking trippy.
This is actually way too uncomfortable.
That would suck actually.
Dude, how the fuck...
How long does this go for?
Alright.
Here we go.
Is it like... Oh, does it... Maybe if I... Okay, no, don't
jump off.
Don't jump off.
Oh, no.
What?
Not that.
We have to...
What do I have to do?
Oh wait, stand over there.
Where?
Here?
Try and connect it.
Yeah, no, one more.
Oh!
Oh god, this is why you're the engineer.
Stand here, where I'm standing.
Okay.
Oh my god, double rainbow.
What the fuck is that?
That's us.
Oh my god, double.
Is that good?
that there's two of us?
No.
Wait?
I thought tower.
Where are you supposed to make?
Go up top right.
I did it.
We did it!
Yeah.
And then...
Whoa.
Does that mean there's gonna be four of us?
I don't know.
My stomach hurt.
Why?
Is it because of the artichokes?
Too much fiber.
Okay.
Would you not to eat all those artichokes?
Oh, I don't like this.
Oh my god, I really don't like this.
Oh, oh.
Oh, finally.
How do we do this?
Oh, oh.
Here you go.
And then I guess I...
Go from here?
Oh, okay.
I'm up and then oh I see I see it yeah yeah there you yeah
and then what do I just bring you over oh I bring you to the
blue yeah I think you can let go of it now yeah but like oh
no I can't yeah oh I can oh wait you can I Okay.
Okay.
I'm on it.
And then we're here together!
What do we do here?
We push it together?
Oh.
Whoa!
Oh, we're refracting it.
We're going up.
What is happening?
Collidoscope time.
This is what's...
This is what's in your collidoscope.
Little people.
Oh, Cody, you have nothing to throw up.
Oh, what the fuck was that?
Oh, it's clay.
I made of clay.
I thought it was made of wood.
You're sniffing it?
I'm like a dog.
You know it's healthy for a dog to...
Oh, God.
Which I built, by the way.
Yeah, you're not the only one in the family who can build
cool stuff.
I built the magic castle?
God, I'm so smart.
over there that'll take us straight there you're sure yes i
am sure would you just trust me i'll try thank you can i go
pee first okay no what the hell don't say anything weird
while i'm gone wait what constitute as weird what's
considered weird guys what would be weird anyway oh my gosh
i got a little little person right here whoop this little
person what do i do with this i shoot the plane the fuck am
i i'm so confused no oh that's a that's a telescope i'm so
confused without my wife she knew what to do all i did was
take credit
The doki way.
I was so good at one thing.
And it was to just take credit.
What do I do?
Oh, hey.
Nice.
I brought it over.
Wait.
That's so... Wait!
Oh, my God.
I could just die with a thing and I'll bring it over.
I assume that's what it's for.
Okay.
Say something weird?
My existence.
No!
Did I cheese that puzzle?
It's not cheesing.
It's strats.
Watch this.
I pick it.
I pick this guy up.
And I'll go down.
Easy.
I got everything.
Right?
That's all of them.
No.
It's okay.
She's not here.
I should never know what I said so I can continue to take
credit for things I didn't do that's the best part oh my god
guys today today I finalized my skin suit design today I not
today last night at like five in the morning I finalized it
I I don't know if you guys are gonna like it but And I don't
have to worry about it anymore.
Thank fucking God.
I was like freaking out about shit for the longest time.
So I'm just happy I don't have to think about it anymore.
Oh yeah, Gumi tried to get me to play TFT.
Because apparently she's like in this.
Uh, wait.
Oh, that cheesed us?
Because like I already got the thing.
Yeah, cheesed it.
Oh my god, that's how I did it.
Oh yeah, and she was trying to get me to play TFT because
she has this TFT tournament or some shit And I was like,
Gumi, I can't even, I only played one game of TFT And like,
there's no way I'm gonna play TFT because the whole thing
about TFT is reading
I was like, there's no way you're gonna get me to play TFT.
I'm not gonna fucking read
almost a team fortress tactics team fight tactics right is
that what it means i don't have the brain capacity for that
all i do is just i i exist i hate it by one weakness reading
i don't have the brain power i bet there's more what is
she's kissing is she kissing the mailman
We're trying to kiss.
We're trying to kiss the mailman?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Chew.
Oh my god.
We can't get going with this barrier in the way.
She's gonna kiss the mailman.
How could she?
In front of him?
Right in front of him?
Just like that?
All right.
Now we just need someone to work the gate.
There you go.
Doki, I went to go get Tom.
I did it!
Gumi!
Yeah, I've glistened the entire time.
I solved the puzzle!
Really?
Yeah!
Now give me a kiss for a good job.
Well done.
Wow, that was so hot.
Oh my god, you're gonna get me excited.
Why am I pee-pee hard?
I want to go get some tombs because I hit them for myself.
Why did you hide it?
Because I have a tombs addiction.
I think they're really yummy.
What is he, tombs?
It...
You don't know what...
Why?
I don't know what tombs is.
It's an antacid.
Oh!
Wait.
We're not, like, fuck your stomach up because you're eating
it out of pure enjoyment and not for...
Yeah, no, you're only supposed to have seven maximum per
day.
and how much how many do you have well you should eat seven
per day oh that is whoa that is not good oh look the
dinosaurs i've never had times for myself because out of
sight out of mind oh what happened to you straight to the
castle root i didn't put the dinosaur there whatever let's
just find a way to clear the track what how i think i've
ever had tums i just like, if I tell me you hurt, I just
suffer.
It only makes you stronger.
When I drink because it helps with the acid from drinking.
Oh, yeah, I don't drink a lot of me, that's why.
What do we do here?
What?
I remember the last time we drank together.
Yeah, that was a long time ago.
I don't know if you remember, but that was a long time ago.
Wait, what's this?
You take the red one on the platform.
Oh, there's a red one.
Where?
They were there.
I just let him go.
Oh.
There you go.
There's the stegosaurus.
Did you know that brontosaurus is not a real dinosaur?
What is it then?
Like, apparently back then when they made the stegosaurus,
they, like, they, like, just pieced together random dinosaur
bones.
And then they're like, this is a brontosaurus.
Hey.
Oh, that's not Stagastores.
That's a...
I don't know what the fuck that is.
What?
I don't know what it's called.
But I can't push that.
You have to do it yourself.
No, no, no.
You have to pull it first.
Oh!
There you go.
Where are Jurassic Park enthusiasts here?
But yeah, apparently like uh wait i did oh i pulled it but
yeah like back then when they did dinosaur stuff they were
like they didn't know like i can't grab it oh because i
didn't go down here you go i'm back i'm back wait what are
you doing grab the other one oh okay No, I don't.
Oh, I do.
Here you go.
Get on.
My lady.
Yeah?
What do you do now?
Bring me back.
That's why I do what it's called you.
Here you go.
okay they said you were wrong grab that one i grabbed it
okay wait no you're supposed to wait for me to grab it but
back in the day when they were constructing dinosaurs like
what we know about dinosaurs back then was like mostly wrong
because the because the the scientists didn't know what the
fuck they were doing and they were just piecing random bones
together until it made one that the other one will disappear
because you you grab i grabbed this and then you knock the
other one i think that changes it trust trust me no trust me
do my idea first how about that entertain my idea first and
then like if i was right if i was wrong you can say i told
you so okay yeah
wow you're wrong Wow!
Wow!
It's like I knew what I was talking about!
And then...
And then I'm gonna grab onto this and you knock it.
Wow!
Who would it say?
I just really don't trust you.
Okay, let me see.
There's something.
You grabbed one now?
Yeah.
Grabbing?
No.
We have to...
I have to grab onto the other one.
There you go.
Get up.
Don't you want to grab onto them first?
Well, I can't.
I can't grab onto that.
Because, like, it's...
Yeah, you can.
But what do you want to grab?
It's one one.
Okay.
Okay, well.
Okay, I'm grabbing on.
Grabbing onto this.
Okay, let go.
Let go.
All right.
Hold the other one.
I'm grabbing onto it.
Okay.
I already did it.
Let me on.
Don't worry.
I'm here.
Look how cute this one is.
The hero is here.
Yeah, but do you have my size?
Size isn't what matters, man.
You taught me that.
It's the blood.
Wait, wait a minute.
What do you mean I taught you that?
Look at him.
Oh, he helped me!
Oh, that's not my fault.
Right over there.
They totally saw that coming.
Okay, don't worry.
I got you.
Look at that.
My guy is still alive.
If your guy wasn't so small, he'd be alive.
What the fuck?
How did you miss?
Because I didn't think you would bring it that far.
I thought you would wait for me to land on it.
I didn't mean that you would bring it to the side.
I don't know.
You should know by...
You're married to me.
You should know by now how I play this game.
Oh, now you don't trust me.
Okay, I got you.
Wait, what am I pulling up?
Why am I pulling up, though?
What is this?
Making a second, watch him.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
I figured it out.
Yay!
Thank you.
Do not worry.
I was afraid to call you a hero.
Your hero is here.
Oh my god, we gave him a concussion!
We're monsters!
No, that was fucked up.
Ew.
Oh.
Where the fuck did the gas come from?
Boy.
Up we go.
Yay!
smell anything your nose has always been sensitive yeah we
have a sensitive nose you're like do these players have
these characters like this mom and dad have friends outside
of just the relationship like do we have friends oh my god
oh my god i feel like it's just us too this is not healthy
we need friends outside of the relationship we isolated each
other we're Like, you can't, I don't, I don't like Michael.
You can't be friends with him anymore.
If you have any guys on your friends list, you're gonna
cheat on me.
Can you delete all of them?
I have a guy who actually did that.
Do you want me to, do you want to look at my phone too?
Do you want, do you want to, here, have all my passwords.
Here, this is all my passwords.
Look, there's my password.
There's my contacts.
Oh, we, oh, yeah.
bad for each other.
I'm going to go this way.
Ow.
Don't sink our boat.
Yeah, don't sink it.
Yeah!
No!
It's a group ember!
Shoot the fucking octopus!
Where are you?
No!
It's a group ember!
I'm not the one for shooting!
We both can shoot!
Wait, we can?
How do I shoot?
Oh!
Oh my god, I'm doing it!
Oh my god, I'm doing it.
I didn't realize that's how you shoot.
We have to shoot this thing!
The fireworks, the fireworks, the fireworks.
Someone was like, don't divorce!
Don't!
Mom, Dad, don't do it!
It's too late.
It's your fault.
All right, we gotta kill this guy.
I'm doing my part.
All right, here we go.
We're doing it.
Die, octopus.
You don't even need to kill them, to be fair, I feel like.
I think so.
Our ship has health.
I think they're just missing.
can just like ride past them is this the water level where
you're gonna shoot a big octopus maybe i hate those levels
oh i fucking knew it we don't have to do this we come in
peace may i don't like their cannons all right where the
water oh wait wait wait
i think we missed vanilla too early yeah This is bad.
What do you mean, Doki?
Doki.
What do you mean?
This is, what happened to, this is a group effort.
What happened to that?
Now it's my fault.
I literally have never said that line.
You're the one that kept saying it.
Now it's my fault just because we took a little damage.
It's now my fault.
I see you.
I remember all the times you ran into the...
Fucking...
It's a wall!
I'm a better person now!
Really?
Yeah, I've changed.
Yeah, you don't have to leave.
I've changed.
You fixed me.
I promise I'll treat you better.
Oh, thank goodness!
Maybe we shoot that one penguin over there.
Straight into the icebox now.
Oh, we can't shoot them.
Don't worry.
I...
What?
If I didn't sign the prenup!
You know, that's more beneficial.
Oh!
Oh my god, you see it?
What?
Oh, the giant octopus.
I see it.
Wait, how do we... How do we dodge that?
How do we do?
Do we shoot it?
Yeah!
Oh, you didn't tell me!
What happened to context clues?
I felt like it was obvious.
I know it was not.
No, it was not.
You know I need to be told what to do.
You know, I...
You know, damn well, I'm a little special, and that's why
you fell in love with me.
This was arranged by your parents.
They lost the bet.
I lost.
Hey, Mr. Octopus.
Don't listen to her.
You are super cute.
Ah, you're so cocky.
Nick Rider!
Ship!
Oh!
Oh, so you're an engineer.
You're so good at engineer.
Fix our ship.
Stop talking, Cody.
And start shooting.
It's the point of having that degree if you can't even fix
our boat.
It's a whirlpool!
Oh, we're gonna shoot the... There we go!
Okay, there we go.
We're good.
We're okay.
Nothing to worry about.
We're not panicking.
Nothing to panic about.
Oh, God.
All right.
Nice.
We got turn around now.
I mean, it's pretty easy so far.
Because he has a giant head.
Why do you say things?
What do you mean?
We got full HP now.
Keep them away.
See?
Oh, God.
It's a duck with dynamite.
Who the fuck gave the kid a dynamite?
What the fuck gave this kid a dynamite?
How does she know how to make a bomb?
Why is it?
No, I got her the castle.
You're the engineer.
This is engineer stuff.
Why would a farmer know how to make a bomb?
Oh god.
Oh wait, how do a fuck do we... Oh, it's okay.
It was just special effects.
It was just a cutscene.
Wait, there's more.
There's... Oh, there's a tentacle!
There's no!
him okay i don't think we can ignore that one guy because
he's just he's just existing
oh no not the flip what the flip hey have you seen that
video that was like a monkey flipping because what and it
had like american music to it what what do you mean by that
i like how
into it a lot more than me oh we're gonna get hit i think we
can just tank this and oh
i'm pretty sure we just tank this and shoot the octopus i
think it's getting tired how can you tell yeah there we go
okay let me get you monkey flip real quick
what the fuck is monkey flip monkey hold on monkey flip okay
like i said in the real world it was and did not try to kill
me.
Oh wait, I did buy her this.
I'm a good dad.
I care about my childhood.
I was...
Here, I sent it to you.
Monkey flip.
Okay, what the fuck?
Whoa!
This is what she said.
Okay, okay, I didn't realize that you were actually singing
the song to monkey flip
I just realized my fucking chrome tap was on
No, I swear I swear by a DMCA I swear I can't DJ it because
of I'm fucking sway That's not my fault what do you think
you sent me the link you had the chrome tab open I didn't
realize I had my chrome audio shit was oh my Sound dive fix
it The worst part is like I replayed it I thought it was
guaranteed.
Monkey flip, monkey flip.
Every time we flipped into octopus, that's where my brain
went.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I just hope we survive this ride too.
How are we still not finished with this chapter?
What the fuck is this level?
The bridge isn't supposed to be up.
Gosh, it's winched by a balloon.
Hey, the fuck uses the word winch.
Yeah, I hate that creepy balloon.
Why'd you have to buy her that?
Yeah.
We can't get to the elephant.
Why?
See, not everything's my fault.
Oh, God.
Oh, what the fuck?
What parent will buy this for the child?
What millennial parent would buy this for the child?
Dude, don't we look like millennials here?
I'm saying, why would millennials buy this?
Millennials won't buy this.
They'll just buy an iPad.
I'm pretty sure this was before iPads existed man There's no
way Rose gave the elephant a crown You know, a queen's crown
Dude, we live in a fucking farm Yeah, I guess so it's her
favorite toy Perfect, so now we're killing a queen Pardon me
Killing who?
No, no, no, no She said chilling Yeah, this was made before
Queen Elizabeth We are really looking forward to Okay, that
does not mean much see well all visitors must prove
themselves worthy of an audience with the queen get a ball
over there and use it to pop the balloon and then you will
this is messed up why is she helping us kill the queen yeah
it's the queen that bad no we're killing the queen man but
it could be implied we literally the storyline talked about
that they said we're chilling with the queen Yeah, but like,
she really believed that.
Oh, I don't have to be there.
Wait.
Oh, and then we do this.
And then it goes over to the other side.
Oh, we did it!
Look at all those blocks and wheels.
I guess it's time for some fast direction again.
Oh, we have to run.
Let's find out.
Okay, let's get this ball going.
I'm ready?
Not that way.
Wait, did you not do it?
the thing i'm holding the ball i'm holding it oh you're
holding it the ball you have to turn the wheel to the right
okay i got it yeah i figured it out together with my lovely
wife look at the sea oh that's so oh look at the sea
okay i i just want to enjoy this beautiful view a little
longer have you ever watched the What play?
Cirque du Soleil.
The circus.
You know what's fucked up?
I went and saw Cirque du Soleil.
Okay, I saw Cirque du Soleil two times in my life.
And the fucked up thing.
Okay, you know how Cirque du Soleil...
Okay, I have to look this up.
But Cirque du Soleil has lots and lots and lots of shows.
Did I fuck up?
Wait, you missed.
Okay.
Okay, let me...
Try that again.
Did you get the other balloon?
Yeah, you have to aim at the one between the bars.
Or you can aim at that one.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Maybe you should.
Maybe you're better at this than me.
Oh, are you sure?
I literally did not say a word and you're just talking to
yourself.
You're literally just talking to yourself.
I don't know what to tell you.
You're like, oh, maybe you're better than it than me.
Are you sure?
Like, I didn't see a single line.
Are you sure this is how you're supposed to do it?
Yeah.
I don't think you can go through that.
Oh, maybe we have to curve it through the side.
I don't think you can.
I think we're supposed to do that one to that one first, and
then that's going to open the gate.
Why would you shoot me now?
Because I'm timing it.
There.
See, look at that.
I timed that fucking perfectly!
You know timings?
Oh my god!
I actually timed that perfectly!
What are you doing?
I didn't know you knew timings, man.
That's gonna close the moment you get there.
Wait, what?
What?
No way to get the center.
There's the center right there.
Why did you not see me hit the other balloon?
did i did but i'm saying there's also this one that we have
to get okay anyway so i saw circus delay has like like like
60 plus shows 60 plus fucking shows and like i remember
going to first circus today when i was like really really
really little and i really enjoyed that because it was like
my first circus delay so i was like all right uh i want to
by the cd of it so then i had it in my i had it in my itunes
for like years and like 10 plus years maybe longer maybe
like 15 plus years and i would list it would come up in my
playlist ever so often because i still have my you know i
listen to it on my iphone and like i always sync it up on my
iphone and then and then i was luckily enough i was able to
watch a new search to slay um uh new realized like what show
it was i was just like oh sir just lay clearly it'll be like
a new show i list the first act it was the same show i
watched 15 plus years ago like i somehow was able to go back
and watch that same show 15 years ago when there is that's
not new that's not I didn't even move my entire thing.
I did not move nothing.
There's 60 plus Circus Salatios.
And I somehow was able to watch the same one.
Like, how?
How is that possible?
I'm sorry, I had to talk about it.
It actually pissed me off that I found out.
Honestly, I can't even remember Circus Salat.
I feel like my mom, like, fall asleep during it.
I only remembered because I was, like, the first act.
I was like, wait a minute.
I know this song.
I was like, why would I know this song if I haven't fucking
watched it?
If I haven't had that song, those songs in repeat for so
long.
Where do we go?
Oh, I have to pass it to you.
Are you ready?
Catch.
Oh my god, we're so good.
It's like we're gamers.
That's nice, honey.
Is that an American?
I have no idea the cut.
No, it's a it's a circus thing The circus in a is like the
one of the bet not one of the biggest circuses in the world
And I somehow was able to watch the same show twice with a
15 plus year gap in between
Like I don't know how it was possible, but like I somehow
was able to do it
Honestly, I didn't know Oh, what the fuck?
We did it.
We wouldn't even coordinate that.
Oh, my god.
It looked at us before it died.
We will.
Thanks for your help.
Yeah, thanks a lot.
Let's get to the castle.
Yay, we committed murder.
I feel like he would know we're committing murder now after
we killed that balloon.
Still can't believe I watched the same show.
Honestly, why did that person let us do that?
I really hated that clown.
Maybe that clown was a fucking asshole.
I mean, look at him.
He looks like an asshole.
Why do I have to kill the queen?
Too many taxes.
Okay.
Viva la France.
What?
You don't know French history?
Hold on.
You said you never finished building the chat.
No, it's more like...
I just did not expect you to see that.
It's time for the revolution!
The elephant!
The gate must be nearby!
Come on!
It's time!
Get the guillotine!
Oh my god!
They must have guillotines!
This is medieval times now!
Oh my god!
No!
Honestly, hold on.
If I had to die...
Yeah.
If you...
If...
If I got to choose how I would die...
Yeah.
I would want to go buy a guillotine.
What the fuck?
Why?
Do you know, like, you can, like, the head start, like, you
know, you still process, like, 10 seconds?
Hey.
Why?
Why a guillotine?
Hold on.
Hear me out.
It would be so cool.
Like, I'm not going to die from old age.
I would go buy guillotine and I would D-Y-I it.
I would make my own.
You know, like, if you'll make your own, it doesn't
guarantee that you're going to get the slice right.
And, hold on.
And I would...
trademark that shit and name it the Gumi Teen.
What the fuck would you already exist?
You can't trademark something that already exists.
What is the Gumi Teen gonna look?
How is the Gumi Teen gonna look different?
Hold on.
I'll show you.
The Gumi Teen has something different to it.
Are you ready?
Yeah, okay.
I'm gonna drive for you real quick.
You're gonna drive for me real quick.
The average guillotine here, I'll even square it.
Okay.
Let me see.
See what this is.
All right.
So the guillotine, it's usually like this, and then it's
like this.
And then it's like this.
And then it has, like, this blade here.
And then you put your little head here.
Right?
And then they usually have a bucket to keep the head.
A bucket?
What?
Oh, you mean like a bucket to catch the to catch the head?
The head.
Yeah.
But that's what the normal guillotine has.
Yeah, that's the normal guillotine.
But this is the guillotine.
First of all, it would have little ears.
Okay?
Let's get that straight.
And then instead of a normal blade, the little blade would
have little teeth and it would look like this and then um it
would be right here and that would be me that would be dry
yourself
that would be me and then hold on i don't even see it yet
what do you mean the string would be a little dog tree the
what would be a little dog tree you know the like pulley
thing how you pull it to make those oh okay oh so the dog
you won't know exactly when it's whenever the dog decides to
pull that's so fucked up that is actually so funny so so the
only thing different about it is that it's controlled by a
dog so you try to say it'll make people feel less bad
because the dog did it is that why no no i'm not gonna make
a dog do it and what's the dog shape for it's just bone
shaped it's just like branding you're not trademarking the
guillotine because you're just no it has freaking teeth and
everything it's just it's like you put on a fortnite skin on
it it's still fortnite you put on a gooby skin on it it's
still a guillotine it's still who trademarked trademarked
we'll be fucked up if somebody trademarked the guillotine so
every time you use the guillotine you have to pay you have
to pay the trademark rights to it that's why we don't even
have wait the guillotine is trademarked as a game wizards of
the coast wait dungeons and dragons trademarked the
guillotine what the fuck okay but they can't trademark the
goomy teen oh my god magic the gathering and dungeon and
dragon's trademark the guillotine that's so fucked up why
did they hold on why if i add a thing instead of a bucket
yeah you goomy it's already trademarked you can't you can't
no you can't trade my the goomy teen it's different it's a
skin you see people trade my shit like fushiki But she is
just a weird weighted ball or like Whoa
Whoa Damn you're so passionate about the magic gravity ball
What the fuck Why did you bring up that the most obscure
shit ever Did you freak out?
Start the game.
Start the fucking game.
And pause the game.
I think you've cooked long enough.
Oh god.
You never even showed me the goomy teen.
You drew all that out and I never got chance to see it.
That's the goomy teen!
You never even showed me the goomy teen!
side what do you mean the right hand side no you did not no
you did not I did not see it you did not show I did not even
I guess it didn't screen share sorry I wasn't listening I
thought you I thought you were gonna screenshot it I thought
you still have the picture can you Can you shot it for me?
No, I already closed!
You get down!
No, you'll never see the gummy teeth.
It looks so different!
I was like, why does she not see this?
Okay, there's a game here.
It's a chicken.
Wait, what the fuck?
Is this squeeze the bird to make it sing?
Oh, I think it's a...
What is this?
Third star, world star.
Oh.
Oh, it's like a rhythm game.
I'm glad I got rhythm.
Kind of cute.
Bump.
When does it get harder?
Easy.
I don't know.
Well done, buddy.
Yeah, this is so easy.
I need to eat another tum.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
Fuck, I didn't realize you can't spam it.
No!
Oh, God, it's getting too hard.
It's getting too hard.
Yes!
Here's Team Blue Buzz.
I'm not that good at rhythm.
It's okay.
I'm good at other things.
That's why you marry me.
I love having a birthday party.
It's like somebody's birthday.
Okay.
Hurry, help!
Give me a sec.
I'm ruining somebody's...
I'm ruining somebody's birthday.
That's fucking right.
Management did not give you a birthday.
Oh, you're helping.
Sticky white substance.
What the fuck?
Oh, what?
Oh, wait.
Look, he's in the other one.
Yeah, I didn't get over for him.
Oh, it's okay.
I got you.
Why are you always in this?
sticky substance what is that anyway oh yeah it's over he is
a pattern I can't believe you ruined their birthday I didn't
ruin it management said they're not allowed to have a
birthday all right let's see if we can get a better view of
the castle where are you going I'm on the team choo choo oh
this is like oh my God, there's like, this is a huge area.
Oh, there's a printer!
There's paint!
What the hell?
Come on, God, I'm making art.
I'm making beautiful art.
Oh, it's so beautiful.
Beautiful is not the word I would use for that.
You're not even looking.
You're on your fucking train.
It's like you love the train more than me.
Maybe I do!
That's fucked up.
How would you ever say that?
What can the train do that I can't?
I'm working right now.
I don't understand.
What are you supposed to do here?
The gate's locked.
There's got to be a way in.
Is there?
I think I found what we're supposed to do.
But like, what if I just want to live here?
It seems like a good place to live.
uh cps evidence number 27 why why are you calling it calling
it on us i'm calling it on you you can't because it's a
group effort if i fuck up as a parent it's on youtube now
why do you keep saying that i'm sure it could be useful but
it's gates god go down oh here you go it's a group effort
you fuck it up individually.
What the fuck it up as team?
Why are you moving it that way?
Oh, it's Jenga!
Wait, what's the point of that?
There was no point.
We had to do this anyway.
No, I couldn't go the other way.
Oh!
You're crazy!
But I like him.
How do we push it?
Did you hear him?
No, I don't...
He said you're crazy, but I like him.
Yeah.
Whoa!
can fix her.
Oh, I have to jump in.
Jump in.
What did it move it together?
Oh, so you're the crazy one, and I'm trying to fix you.
Okay.
I knew I was the norm.
Any man that said my ex, dude, I dated a guy who said all my
exes were crazy.
He was the problem.
That's full of God.
Are you trying to say I'm the problem?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We're not here to cause trouble.
I am.
That guy, me.
Wait.
That sounds a lot like...
Queen of the Magic Castle.
In short, Her Majesty.
Yes, you mean Her Majesty.
Can you take us to her?
It's kind of urgent.
The Queen does not grant audience with peasants.
peasants we made them okay I built yeah all right I even
came up with the name magic castle so if it wasn't for me
you excuse my underling mom underling yes we are messengers
from a land far far away we come with a very important
letter for her majesty and it over oh well we need to see
how much a letter in words Whoa!
Whoa!
What?
This book is a fucking asshole.
Yeah, a snitch.
You snitch?
Yeah, Dick Rider.
He's lying.
Then why don't you show the letter to Her Majesty?
Well, maybe I will.
okay so the thing with the letter is it's kind of complex
it's a speech letter exactly because i can't write
hold on i received a screenshot is this like off-brand lego
are we two ports by real lego i've sent you the screenshot
that my moderator sent me Oh my god, they have gave us a
toilet.
There's different toys that look just like that.
I don't remember what.
It was like, it wasn't Legos.
They were bigger.
No, it's Play Mobile.
It's in Play Mobile, like, it's Play Mobile, like, like
Lego.
Anyone hear us?
I know, like, Lego has like, screenshot.
I know Lego has, like, baby Lego.
Duplo.
Oh, Duplo.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you mind?
What are you doing?
I built that.
Yeah, I can see that.
The toilet has no pipes.
Yeah, it's a toy castle.
Toys don't go to the bathroom.
Yeah.
Toys don't need to eat.
That's why did they have a pie?
That's right.
It was a waste of food.
Those toys don't need to eat anyway.
Ew.
It's like paper.
How am I like weaker than paper?
Oh, no.
Bro, am I getting too flabby?
Did you shard yourself or something?
Why are you pulling your pants?
What the fuck?
I think you sharded.
Stop!
Chart?
Why?
This is a kids game.
This is a children's game.
This is PG.
Yeah, we are a PG friendly stream
Didn't know what shark means Oh, oh my god, we killed him
You killed him.
We killed him.
Oh Oh, I get a cool fire sword.
Where the fuck do you get the cool weapons?
Oh, wait, but then I you get melee I get FPS.
You know what I'm fighting?
with that.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
It's like, wait, I know this type of game.
Okay, wait.
I'm trying to look at my abilities.
It's like a roguelike.
No, no, there's like a specific...
I know this type... I played this type of game before.
Alright, here, yeah.
I got you.
Wait, can you open these chests or no?
No, we can't.
Is this... Is this...
No, there's like... There's like... It's like an old...
Wait, is this you?
You have to go through it with me.
you oh my god there's like an old game that was just like
this but i don't remember it was like an arcade game that
was just like this all right give me a sec let me kill this
oh nice did we got snipers over there i have to teleport for
you okay you gotta hurry oh you gotta hurry oh i'm getting
beat up okay i got you i got you i'm good Nice, okay, I got
hit.
Is it gauntlet?
I might need gauntlet.
Because I remember it looked just like this.
Dude, I have a fucking fire tornado move.
Wait, how do we...
How do I get over here?
What do you do?
Do you beat this up?
Wait, can I dash through this?
No, I can't.
I'm too fucking...
I can't dash through that.
Is there some way to open that up for me?
Oh, you stay right there.
Oh, I have to go back.
Okay.
I'm too chunky.
Wait, watch this.
Ice.
Oh, look at that.
No, wait, I got you.
I did it.
Wait, that's you.
I don't have to do anything now.
I don't have to do...
Oh, I might be dying.
Don't die.
Okay, I'm back, I'm back.
You can die now.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'll chill here.
Oh, I have to do this.
I think she's dead?
No, there's still one more.
All right, I gotta kill this one guy.
I believe in your wife!
A fire tornado him.
Oh, chest.
I feel like the chest is, like, useless, to be fair.
Yeah, you have to get them.
Don't worry.
I'm pretty sure your sword can make it over.
There's, like, range.
This is you.
Yeah, this is you.
This is 100% you.
I'm too far.
Yay!
Whoop!
Where am I?
Oh, I keep looking at you thinking that's me.
It's okay.
Oh, pio.
Oh, yes.
Traps are the prisoners.
Oh!
Oh, I accidentally ulted.
Okay, freeze.
Don't worry, the hero is here.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's crazy how many different like genres this game has
I'm coming over I'm helping
You're just mad that you have to rely on me.
Oh stop
That's what you get for not believing in my ice powers No, I
did.
It's just you took too long.
Are you blaming me?
A person that has control here?
With the ices?
I made you a bridge.
I made you a bridge and this is the things I get.
Okay, bud.
You could have built one before we got tiny, huh?
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Oh, shit!
What?
What the fuck is that?
It looks like a baking cone.
Okay, go, go, go.
Okay, we gotta go.
We gotta go fast.
Wait, which way is this way?
Oh, I went the wrong way!
Wow!
I keep going the wrong way, Gumi!
Oh, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me!
I got it, I got it, I got it!
Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
See, we're okay.
What the fuck gave this fucking...
A baby a thing.
Goodbye.
It's like Toy Story.
Doom.
There's so many references, sis.
We made it.
We did it.
Now it's time to kill the queen.
Bowser?
Oh, crap.
I forgot about the immortal troll.
The immortal troll?
Wait, he's taking zero damage.
Because we have to do the chains!
Oh!
Okay, I'm going to the chains.
I'm going to the chains.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my gosh, okay, I'm going to the chains.
I'm going to the chains.
Bait him here.
Get over here, little man.
Nice.
And then we bait him into the thingy.
He has to charge it, right?
Come on, go into the little hole.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm doing it.
Goodbye.
Toy story.
No way to get a mug ever again.
Yeah, what she said.
Oh, oh, May, come on.
Over here.
let's go my fire sword is so cool that's it oh oh joki what
you left my game crashed it said ea servers what it says the
other player left no they have to do that again the ea
servers no
crawler again oh my god we just made it the curse passed
over to you oh apparently that was a terminator reference
not doom i saw it on doom though sorry terminator reference
i remember seeing oh wait we did we saved wait a minute it
saved this is my old chess board okay do you know Yeah, I
used to be in the chess club.
Because I don't have the time.
Plus, it's not a toy.
You know, it was my grandmother's.
Oh!
She would appreciate that it's actually being used.
Oh, no, no.
I don't think we're actually playing chess.
Chess boards alive.
There's no way.
What if we don't know how to play chess?
Yeah, it's still a...
We have to kill the king and the queen.
Kill the queen first!
The queen knows the most literally...
We gotta kill...
Wait, if we kill the king, that means the game ends
instantly, right?
Because that's how it should work.
Okay, I go for the king.
I see you.
I'm going for the king.
Wait, is it healing?
No, I'm actually hurting him.
Okay, that's good.
Okay, I was worried.
Don't worry, I got this!
We're tag team!
Okay, wait, how did you die?
No, no, no, no.
You died, though.
It's okay.
The castle can only go in the cross.
I'm teaching you chess.
Do you like this little lesson?
Unit...
Wait, actually, do you know how to play chess?
What the hell?
I got it over!
Okay, they explained why the fucking horses and knights
aren't going diagonal.
And in L shape.
Horses don't go diagonal.
They go in an L shape.
I said it in L shape!
It's why I'm here to teach you about chess.
Mansplainer.
I don't know.
I didn't get hit once.
Because I don't know how to play chess.
Why does it have no handle?
I think it's because the queen gets summoned and shit.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
Ugh.
Oh, oh yeah, I remember.
What the fuck?
Did I make this door?
Like...
How?
Yeah.
Oh, that was not how you opened the door.
No!
We lost our wizard powers!
How are we gonna kill the elephant now?
I don't know.
Wait a minute.
That's right, I forgot.
I color coded them the opposite way around to fool
intruders.
What?
It's actually very smart if you think about it.
Who the fuck's an intruder?
Why would you do that?
Who's gonna intrude the castle?
Still gonna miss my outfit.
Why do we put electricity there?
Like, for a kid's toy?
What if my daughter forgot?
Yo, she's gonna shock her finger.
Greetings, your majesty.
hello you don't need to bow I'm cutie the elephant oh my
gosh she's so cute do you want some cookies I actually love
cookies how come do you know I hate to stuff your face with
cookies let's just do this you sound unhappy you can tell me
what's wrong that's what friends are for no no nothing's
wrong it's it's great everything's like super great well I
can see you're not happy you need a hug I kind of do Aww
What are you doing?
Let's kill her Whoa Whoa No, no, no, we don't want to kill
you We just kind of have to It's a little bit Oh my god What
the fuck is wrong with you, Gumi?
You're the one that said it You're like, we're gonna kill
her And I was like whoa no you made this plan no no no this
is a group effort when we get married when we got married
every idea is as a group effort there's no eye in marriage
why does fuck does she keep turning around to look back at
us oh my god to the moon oh my god do you see that we see
that what's showing on the box oh yeah there is his elbow.
Oh my god.
Where was she?
Guess that's the way the cookie grumbles.
That's fucked up, Gumi.
Oh, it's like the cookie monster!
We don't want to do this, but we have to.
We have to make Rose cry.
It's nothing personal.
We just need to- See, you said it!
No, no, no.
You said it first.
I just went with you.
I just enabled you.
Oh, it's a crane game.
I'm really good at this Man, always changing the narrative
Whoa No, that's not it.
We have to you have to Okay, I'll do the I'll do the grabby
thing I'll do the grabby thing.
I made a fucking claw machine for her Bro, I'm the perfect
dad Holy shit Okay, we need to time this better Okay, she's
got she's got it She goes in a circle Yeah, she goes in the
fucking circle.
Okay, we're right here.
Okay.
One, two, three.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Why did you move?
Perfectly!
Okay.
You put it over here.
Okay, okay, and I'll time it.
Watch this.
Maybe we go up here because I'm impatient.
Maybe here.
I'm impatient.
Boom!
There you go.
Perfect timing.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
That is so fucked up.
How are we gonna kill this thing?
You know how you said it looks like a cookie monster?
Yeah?
It kind of reminds me of those old YouTube videos.
Oh, like, let me fire my laser.
Yeah!
Let me fire my laser.
I don't wanna do this.
I think her head's gonna pop off.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, this head's definitely gonna pop off.
I think we're popping off her head.
oh at least it's not the head we gotta get her to the edge
of the bookshelf edge of the bookshelf bro this is bro
where's your guard alright let's go it's time to take her to
the edge come on goomy we already made it this far we can't
back up now we made it this far
It's all right.
Oh, God.
They're begging to not die.
Oh, my God.
She's struggling.
Get her.
She can't get away.
My God.
Who did I marry?
I married a boy.
It's too late.
We're running this far.
If we let her live, she's going to tell the cops.
Stop resisting.
Oh!
Pump!
She doesn't need the ear!
She doesn't feel no...
She doesn't feel pain.
Don't worry.
She feels zero pain.
She's a dog.
Down she goes.
Goodbye.
See?
She was lying about feeling pain.
Humi, come on.
No, you can buttermash faster than this, Humi.
Come on.
This is a group effort.
We agreed to this when we got married.
I did agree to committing murder.
Lord, lift the king.
Did he?
Kitty.
Did we just kid?
Imagine being a kid.
You're dancing your doll ripped up out of nowhere.
Yeah, come on, darling.
I love how, like, we threw her leg and ears, too.
Are you okay?
Cry.
Oh, no, cutie.
Poor cutie.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry you hurt yourself.
What?
Success.
We made it look like an accident.
May, I think it's working.
Don't we need her tears?
Yes, come on.
All right, we gotta get down there.
Quick, before she stops.
This way.
This is so fucked up.
Like, this is the part where it's fucked up.
We were happy about her crying.
Yeah, like, our kids cried.
Fuck yeah!
Time to dance in the rain.
Let's go dance.
Sweet, sweet tears.
Yeah!
It's shower time!
Why is the spell not breaking?
We don't know.
The tears should be the cure.
Oh, no.
So we killed the elephant for no reason.
We're stuck like this.
The tears should be the-
What's this?
Oh my god, it's her runaway letter.
Is it actually?
there's no way where the fuck would she go i think it's a
letter from rose listen dear mom and dad i'm sorry that i
did this to you oh she thinks it's her fault and she's right
all you have to do is i think this is it this is the answer
go on how do we break the spell all you have to do is whoa
whoa not so fast hey give that back that's our letter you're
not ready
Please, your relationship!
No!
Maybe we just like never have kids, don't we?
Take it out of here!
Yes, I did!
Into four pieces!
What?
That did not look like four pieces, man.
Yeah, that's a big ass letter.
It's time to dive deeper into your souls and collect the
four letter pieces!
What?
Bro, fuck his book!
Are we just going to ignore the fact we kid cry?
Yeah, we're going to ignore the fact that she's crying?
Like...
This is abduction!
Yeah, we're...
Oh yeah, you're right.
We don't need the top two.
We already read the top two.
Oh, we're in therapy.
I told you we need a couple's counseling.
Give us the ride of your life.
Give us...
Bravo!
You refer to us instead of me.
You're a team now.
I know we're not a team.
we don't have time for this time good man that will be our
first topic now do you give each other enough time do you
know it's crazy you know what we actually we don't yeah yeah
we don't she is never at home oh yeah you love your job more
than you love me i'm working for both of us i'm working you
don't even make money but i make sacrifices You think time
is limitless.
That's ridiculous.
It is.
No sense of time.
No, it's not.
Insights.
We're making progress already.
Great.
Get ready.
Hey.
Woo.
Look, we made progress.
Look at that.
We made progress.
I think that couples therapy is working.
I don't want to go to therapy anymore.
I think it's over.
I checked out.
My chat was like, I sacrificed my bow pass for you.
Like, that's how deep my love is.
That I paid for!
That we pay for!
We share a bank account.
It's our money.
Is that because I'm the only one working?
Whoa!
And got it.
With no sense of time, you will now be able to control that.
I got the power!
I got the power Whoa Oh you have the clone I have time
What's this?
Is that me?
God Why am I so old?
Where's your hairline?
Look at that Look how far your hairline goes It's a style
It's a choice God you sound like this Because I That is me
Might as well be Okay I need to use the bathroom right back
Don't be weird to my chat The book said we have to make the
two meet So what?
Let's just do it We need Rose's letter to break the spell
Chat I'm going to tell you guys a story Oh my story should I
tell What?
What story have I not talked about in a while?
That Doki's chat probably hasn't heard.
Maybe the OGs.
I don't know.
What do I have?
I didn't know they made the plush of it.
I think, um, when I was younger, I had a nightmare.
This is completely unrelated.
I just thought about the paste eating kid from Powerpuff
Girls, but when I was younger, I used to have a lot of
nightmares about this one specific episode that had a mime
in it.
And like, I think... No!
Actually, no!
This reminded me!
I actually have a good story.
So when I was in third grade, second third grade, I kept
having nightmares.
They were recurring nightmares of my mom driving and
abandoning me at a trailer with the Kanker sisters from Ed,
Ed, and Eddie.
And it would be different each time.
Like, the first time I had it, she just abandoned me there.
The second time, they abandoned me there, but my, like,
step-sister removed was in the car.
And then in the third one, she abandoned me there.
But they started shooting fucking ARs.
They had ARs and everything, and I had to take cover behind
the couch.
hiding me on a couch like this.
So scared.
And like, you can see the bullet holes through the couch.
Anyways, um, my teacher gave us an assignment that was like,
oh.
Write down your dreams of late.
Like, your dreams of lately.
And I wrote that down, and then they pulled me aside.
Like, is everything okay, Crystal?
I'm like, yeah.
I mean, I don't know what it is.
I'm gonna have that dream again, but it's okay Anyways What
the fuck kind of dream was that?
What the fuck?
It was a recurring dream Our recurring dream?
What are you okay?
I don't know.
I was second grade me that was second grade dog second
grade?
Oh, so I thought I saw the I saw the gummy teen Guys, this
is what the gummy teen looks like so The This is basically a
skin.
It's a fortnight skin.
You put a fucking DLC skin on top of a guillotine That's
Okay, don't you see those people who trademark their own
special knives and shit?
No, it's still what?
It's still a knife and then they name it something else.
It's still a knife.
What do you mean?
Yeah, but they name it something else.
Okay.
I fixed it There you go.
I fixed it It's your turn to fix this.
Wait, what happened?
Oh, did you not make it through?
You have to time it.
Oh, I thought you made it through.
I made it through.
There you go.
I got the cool powers.
Wait, what's your power?
I can make clones of myself.
Oh, I think you can make a clone of yourself here.
But hi.
You have to make clones to do the lever.
Oh.
No, no, no.
I go back in time.
What?
Hey, maybe you can reach the door before it closes with your
clone.
Yeah, see?
Oh, I thought you meant you want me to leave it to the
lever.
No, no, I want you to have your clone to go over there.
Bing.
Yay!
What's this?
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, hook onto this hook.
Wait.
What?
What are you bringing it?
Oh, no.
Oh, here, here, here.
And then...
I make it go up here?
Oh, my God.
We're so smart.
We're so fucking smart.
Yeah, whoever designed this knew what they were.
Who designed this?
Oh, shit!
Do I respawn next to you?
Oh, no, I don't.
I should be able to make it.
Make this jump.
Yay!
You have to do the time thingy over there.
Where?
Oh, here.
I'm rewinding.
Right, here it is.
Jump.
Not that thingy.
No, it's this.
That's the only thing I can rewind.
No, look over there.
Oh.
Wait, what?
I did it.
Wait, but where do you go?
Oh.
Yeah, that's the thing.
Where do you go?
There's a button up there.
I think you jump over there.
Yeah.
And then what?
And then you leave your clone?
Hold on, hold on.
Yeah, let it fall.
Oh!
We did it!
And then I'll let it go up.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
And then you press the button!
Team!
I like how you said we did it, but I figured it out.
Yeah, but you need me to be able to do it.
There's no I in team.
There's no I in marriage, too.
Oh.
There you go.
Fixed it.
What do we do with this?
Why did you fix it?
Nothing.
Oh, but it looks so beautiful.
We needed this thing.
Oh, this.
Not this.
I can't...
What?
There's only one I can pull.
I can't pull the other thing.
Yeah, so I think I have to do this.
Yeah, see?
I told you.
That's what it fixes.
Oh, the owl made it now.
And then, boop, we get launched over.
And then I send you back up.
And then you leave your clone.
And then I go, boop.
And then you clone.
And then you go up.
See?
I feel like a little rat.
Rat.
We are the rats.
There we go.
And then we just go here.
Oh!
I accidentally pressed A.
It's just an accident.
What?
I agreed with you.
I said sure!
God.
What?
Gaslighting.
Pretty usual.
I'm gaslighting?
I said sh- I agreed with you.
Why are you pressing?
Oh, they're like cuckoo clocks.
But you have to leave...
Do you have to leave your clone?
Wait, you have to leave your clone on one of them, maybe?
Yeah.
Yeah, because, like, um...
Yeah, and then you go back.
There you go.
Oh!
Rewind that shit.
I'm rewinding?
I think...
Yeah, rewinding.
Don't you have to...
Oh, can you not rewind and stand on it?
No, I think you have to stand on it.
now what the hell whoa this is like scene punk is who built
this i did because no one else is going to take credit i'll
take credit for it you didn't even let me have a chance you
just said it in a split second i'll be honest if you really
wanted to take credit for it you'd be faster
Yeah, because I did it.
Yeah.
He was just blabbing on and on about time.
Oh, yeah.
I built his smile.
Well, it's true.
Oh.
You're never at home.
Yeah.
Why are you not home?
Huh?
Is it because of Jerry at work?
I don't know.
Who the fuck is Jerry?
What does he have that I don't?
Not my choice.
A job.
What do you mean?
Being a house husband is a job.
How fucking dare you?
I changed your diapers!
I also changed her diapers.
I come home.
You went to do engineer stuff.
I'm going to work.
I'm working hard.
I come home.
You're sleeping on the couch and she's doing her homework
alone in the room.
And I still have dishes to do.
clean the dishes i did i totally cleaned the dishes it's not
my fault that you use all the dishes like do you really need
to use why don't we have paper plates sorry you have to
leave your clone i think right
there yeah
What?
Why didn't it press it?
No, I did.
We had to wait.
Look at these clock people.
Wait, what's over here?
What the fuck is over here?
Where's this other area?
This area is fucking...
Oh, I found it!
I already found the other bell.
I think that was just a regular bell.
I found the regular bell.
It's actually beautiful.
Wee!
Yay!
Game!
Where is that?
Mom?
I'm trying to find you right now.
Jesus Christ.
This is a huge area.
The hell tower.
Holy fuck.
We taught our kid the word hell?
What the fuck?
Okay, how do we play this?
Follow the bubbles and reach the finish line.
What?
Oh, it's like spiral where we have to follow the thing.
Come on.
This is not fair.
Why are you faster?
You gotta hit start.
no you have to head start you're faster than me there's no
other reason there's no other reason there's no other reason
oh god i'm coming over i'm coming over i'm coming over
where does it go nice oh this way this way this way This
way, this way, this way.
I did it!
Whoa!
Yeah!
Not a cope anymore, because I was.
Oh, the artichoke.
Oh, God.
I think I need to eat another tub.
Not a cope.
Oh, there's another game over here.
There's another game over here.
Follow me.
Hey.
Yay.
Wait, where are you, Gumi?
There's a game right over here.
The chickens.
What is this?
Oh, it's a shooter.
Did you call it a sheep chicken?
No, there's a chicken next to the horse.
There you go.
Get on the horse.
I'm ready.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Crouch.
Avoid obstacles to reach the finish line.
Crouch and jump.
Alright.
How do I crouch?
Like, is it pressing?
It said it.
Oh, it's like this!
Wee-oo!
Yay!
Oh my god, look how beautiful my horses.
Wee!
Did that be honest?
I like the horses that look like they're wearing socks.
You know what I mean?
Oh, I know what I mean, yeah.
really fancy no no it's not fair no what do you mean it's
not fair when i don't win it's not fair because
of your horse your horse comment i got
your horse comment distracted me how are you missing oh no
i'm stupid.
Is this part of the game?
Is this...
What the?
It kind of reminds me of Bayonetta.
Ooh.
It reminds me of that cheap game.
You know that one?
Catherine?
Oh my god.
I've always wanted to play Catherine.
I can play Catherine!
I wonder if a Catherine will be a good game to stream.
I've always wanted to play that game.
It's always been, like, super interesting.
Whoa, no!
I fell on Hell Tower.
Can you do this for...
Wait, do I have to be there?
Can you just...
Oh, I fell.
Oh, okay.
I thought you could do it for me.
I fell, too.
Oh, my God.
This is truly as hell.
Is this even worth it?
I don't think this is part of the game.
I feel like this is not mandatory.
There's no way that this is mandatory.
Dude, why is this so hard up there?
Oh my god!
Are we just bad?
Are we just bad video games?
There's no way.
I thought we were gamers.
What happened?
I'm at the wall jump part.
Okay, I can just...
Okay, I'm scared.
How do we wall jump here?
Oh, God.
No, that was scary.
No!
Do we have to...
Oh, my God.
I hate how this moves.
No!
You distracted me!
I can't believe that you distracted me.
I did do nothing.
You distracted me.
I can't believe you do this to me.
I can!
I give up.
I'm- This is not- It is part of the game!
No way it's not!
There's no way!
This is not part of the story!
I'm gonna fight.
fish there's a fishing let's just fish i don't okay see if i
can catch any i'm gonna fish and you go do your thing i
gotta catch
wait what the why couldn't i catch it come on come on come
on come on come on come on husband's gotta bring in a juicy
fish I'm gonna feed the family.
Come on.
Come on The most exciting gameplay is right here
Got a catch are you happy look I Got us some food
I got us some food.
Oh my god Look I got more food.
I told you it didn't matter.
It was just fireworks We got his fish, though.
Oh, look at that.
I can't even see the fireworks.
I can't even see it from here.
You have to...
Oh, there you are.
I see it now.
So beautiful.
I'm the real gamer.
It's okay.
I caught us some fish.
Like a good husband.
I provided food on the table.
The Hell Tower does not provide food.
That's all I'm saying.
It provides joy.
Something that you didn't bring to the table.
Whoa, I'm the fun dad.
I built the castle.
Oh, so we need to move the clouds.
You have to move the clouds somehow.
How do we move?
move the clouds.
It must be something you have to do, because I just rerun
time, and then the rain falls down.
Are you guys freaking out?
It sounds like it's your house, right?
This guy is dancing.
Look at him go.
He's dancing.
He doesn't care.
Where is it?
I don't know.
I have no idea where it could be.
Oh.
How do you move it?
No, that's not it.
Oh.
Don't worry, I got this.
My magic power.
Dad power.
Rain!
Okay, we need that, yeah.
And then...
There you go.
They're happy now.
I don't think that person's dancing.
I think they were asking for help.
No, no, look at him.
He's...
Look at him.
dance he's dancing he's having a great time we just like me
oh oh i'll grab this one oh he's fishing too look at him go
can i fish with him oh there's a timer here oh shit that's
dangerous okay i have to do this oh we have to we have to go
back Okay, okay, we have to do this again.
And then I have to snag it.
I fucking, I fucked up Wait.
Come back, come back.
I messed up a little.
Just a little.
Just a little bit.
I made one simple mistake.
Jake.
Every dad gets one.
Oh, my dad, you've had more than one.
This is my one.
There you go.
Look at that.
Go.
Yeah, that's me.
That's me.
Oh, they're lumberjacking.
Where are they going?
to the clock this is our mansion open it's a clock tower now
to just open this gate should be a breeze why oh oh wait
match make it match oh wait which I'm the tiny one I did it
joki is the one who held this marriage what do you mean I am
the glue to this marriage without me this marriage will fall
apart I even bought his paper plates I even bought his paper
plates so we don't have to waste water you remind me of my
old roommate so we don't have to waste water see we're
saving water bills we're saving water bills by not Is that
why you haven't showered in three weeks?
Is that where we're going?
You don't know that.
I can smell it.
I have clones.
The secrets of the smaller towers.
You see?
Here's a thought.
The clone doesn't do enough.
Straight away.
Yeah, we need to get back to our real bodies as soon as
possible.
Don't stress me.
Time is an illusion.
There's only now.
Can't you feel it?
He thinks I'm right.
I told him time doesn't matter.
Oh my god, hold on.
Did you know?
Not did you know, but like...
My friend has a little sibling.
Who's, I think, 19 now?
And...
He, like, leaves.
A little straw with a toothpaste.
Okay, he leaves a little toothpaste on his little sibling's
toothbrush.
Yeah.
To check.
if their sibling brushes their teeth what apparently the
toothpaste has not disappeared it's been oh my god yeah
that's that is disgusting i know where are you going to okay
i'll go to the left then i'm gonna go to the left wait what
do we do we have to be at the same one come here we have to
be at the same one look at that tower we might be able to
land okay i thought we had separate it's fine i'm good at
flying wow look at me go wow don't worry your heroes here
i'm trying to figure out how to get off
look at that first try did the dad make this yeah i made
this creepy cavern why is there any here.
Turns out that sibling of my friends also like one shower
because they just want to play games.
What the?
Oh, so he's a knee.
He's like, wait, I think this is a puzzle.
I don't think we know the answer yet, right?
I do, do sun.
Why?
Yeah, I don't think we know the answer yet.
I think we have to figure it out here.
Where's the bees, cat and dog, sun and moon, no?
But like, I don't know the answer.
Oh, but...
What the hell?
Is that a sculpture?
Oh, shit.
What does he want?
Oh, come back.
Whoa!
How do I get to the other side?
Oh, okay.
Oh, hold on.
Oh, you have to...
Oh, thank God you're on that side and I'm doing this.
Okay, B first.
B first.
B.
Okay.
Bird.
Cat.
Dog.
Sun.
We did it!
Yay!
Yippee!
Woo!
Hello.
It's your beautiful husband.
What?
Because you married me for my looks and charm.
We did it!
Wait, what?
How else did you marry me?
We're gonna bomb the castle?
Oh, yeah.
What's wrong with this?
scheming bombs in our little kids place.
They look dangerous.
I think they're trying to teach us how to make...
What?
Is this subliminal messaging?
Suddenly, once low, castles up.
Alright, my bird.
Wee!
Don't worry, I'm not on the list.
Because I'm not American.
Alright, I'm here.
I made it before you did.
But I can't get off my bird.
My bird won't let me.
How did you get off the bird?
My bird likes me.
Oh, okay, I did it.
I had to wait for you to get off the bird.
No, you did not.
It's because my bird likes me too much so she doesn't want
me to get off.
I think it's because I had control of my bird.
it it's because it's on green now you have to wait oh yeah
see it's yeah you should have waited you should have waited
why did you jump then because i'm a little special mommy
says i'm a special little girl you're pissing me off good
yeah i made the bridge back there i thought you need to go
down this Do I?
Yeah.
Because it goes on the red first.
There.
What did you do?
Oh, you changed it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my gosh.
This takes so long.
Wait, oh.
Oh!
No, why did you do that?
I didn't need you already.
I was ready.
ready jump on it red i did it now you have to make it red
again why did you have to make it red again it goes green
i just said don't do well let's gonna reinforce this i'm i'm
i don't i just i had too much negative reinforcement do you
know what you're doing yeah i just i'll be honest
don't what do i do there we go we did it there we go easy
You're pissing me off.
Yay.
I think it's fully stopped.
Like the thing.
So like it won't turn anything else.
Yeah.
Trust me.
Go, yeah.
See, jump, jump through it.
What are you doing?
I don't trust you.
Oh.
Okay.
And then, yeah.
And what are you doing?
You didn't trust me!
I can tell you this.
I didn't trust me there!
There you go.
You're right, I didn't trust you!
Alright.
I'm spinning, spinning, spinning, spinning, spinning,
spinning.
Wow!
What the heck is that?
Force field?
Yeah.
Wait, what do we do now?
Where's our crows?
Oh, there we are.
I would never forget you, pro.
There we are.
Well, you didn't say anything.
Oh, wow.
Why can't it go through the force field?
Because I don't think we've, like, we didn't force it
enough.
Wait, we have to...
Oh, I know what we have to do.
What do we have to do?
Let's see what you can do.
Oh!
Wait, we're just...
You get it from the sky, man.
Oh, this guy!
Oh my god!
He's got one!
I got the bomb.
Aim.
Oh, okay.
I just aim and throw.
I figured it out.
The controls.
I killed mine.
I killed mine, too.
I literally see it alive.
Look, I'm shooting it from here.
See, I told you.
I killed mine.
I told you I did it.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Oh, I'm here.
Yay!
Why are they stuck down there?
I have to rewind.
Because I need to bring them back up.
There you go.
Yay!
And then... and then what?
Go in.
Is there something we have to do?
What do we have to do?
They need something.
What the fuck?
Oh, maybe?
Oh, you have to get to wall jump the other side.
I like my bird.
You have to wall jump the other side.
Gumi, I'm literally doing this right now.
I'm not.
I like my bird.
We can take the bird home after.
That's a cool...
I like this.
I like this mechanism.
Yay!
I like my
bird.
You are to me.
I don't like that sound.
Do we really have to follow them?
Yes.
We'll never get out of here.
Fine.
Ladies first.
What the fuck?
I'm a gentleman!
I'm letting you go first, see?
We both were to drop down anyway.
What?
Oh shit, I built this.
Why did I build this?
Yeah, you do something!
Someone help!
Wait, what did you do?
I almost thought we wouldn't make it.
I was a genius, that's why.
I know what you did!
You put a clone on the other side!
Oh my god, look tiny rats!
Tiny rats!
Oh my god, look at these rats!
Rats!
We are the rats!
Okay, time to rewind.
You're playing a soccer night.
A rat.
Where are you opening?
Oh, we're close.
the door.
No, we're going up.
Yeah, we close the door and go up.
Both things can happen, Gumi.
You can multitask.
Look, there's us.
There's us.
Oh my god, it's so beautiful.
I did this smile.
This place is beautiful, but it doesn't make any sense.
Why do you always have to make sense of everything?
Yeah.
someone has to i don't know it's not someone has to whoa you
need a fun dad we all know the good cop is the dad and the
bad cop's the mom i'm the fun dad i'm the fun dad so like
when our daughter is mad she yells at you and then when she
wants to have fun she goes to me it's like typical
Oh, that's supposed to be normal.
It's so normal.
The dad takes you out to have fun and ha- What the fuck?
Wait, what the fuck?
Bro, what the fuck is that?
Wait, where are we supposed to go?
I'm going here.
I don't know where I am.
Go, go.
Where am I?
Where are you?
Wait, I think we went on the wrong area.
Okay, I'm going back to you.
What do you mean we went on the wrong area?
We went on the wrong side.
Oh my god, it's a keyblade.
Holy.
I'm here.
Holy what?
Whoa, are you okay?
Whoa.
I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
Fun dad's coming.
Hello, sweetie.
Fun dad is here.
Are we sure this is the right way?
Are you sure?
I feel like we're supposed to...
Revive it!
I can reach!
Oh, I could.
Okay.
Yay.
There we go.
And then you have to put your clone.
And then...
Ta-da!
And then we go this way.
And then clone time.
I'm glad I'm the time person so I can do less work.
I'm glad this is where I'm at.
Alright, and then...
I think I have to do it higher up here, right?
Whoop!
Where does this turn?
Okay, and then where does this turn?
Then where do you have to go?
Where do you have to go from here?
You've turned it.
I'm turning, I'm turning, I'm turning, I'm turning.
Oh, I think I turned too fast.
Where are you supposed to go?
Where are you supposed to go to?
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Well, at least you don't have to do it all the way.
Where are you?
Oh, you're here.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh, I can't see.
I hate this camera angle.
Ready?
Are you ready?
Just drop down.
Here, see?
And then I just turn, I just turn.
You just have to run with the thing and I just turn.
Okay, then what?
I've turned the wrong way, sorry.
That's what I thought.
Wait, and then what?
How do you get to the other side?
I guess that you put your clone?
You put your clone or something?
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, I see it.
Yeah, but like you have to you can't get there.
I told you there's no way you can get there You have to put
your clone Put my clone where I don't know somewhere Why do
you turn it without saying anything?
You can look at the visuals I'm lucky to see how we get
there.
Okay, I turned it maybe put a clone here Clone where just
where you're standing.
Yeah Yeah, yeah, and then we turn.
Yeah, see?
No, not now!
What do you mean, see?
Okay, just put that here.
And now I want to keep turning.
Because it gets closer.
When I turn it, you see that?
It gets closer.
I don't think my club moves with it, does it?
No, like, the thingy turns.
The thingy gets closer.
So like, okay, so if I turn it all the way to the other
side, it like gets closer.
Like the other thing gets closer.
Doesn't it?
You're pissing me off.
I'm so confused.
I'm confused.
My brain hurt.
My brain hurting.
This went the entire time?
And you just stopped turning it?
We did it!
Oh my god, we did it!
Why did you stop turning it?
I'm so proud of us!
I thought there was a limit to how much you could turn.
We did it!
Yay!
Woo!
We did it!
Yay!
Oh my god.
Get over here.
Wait, I thought we had to do the one year.
Okay, I'll turn the key.
Okay, I'm coming back to turn the key.
It's time to turn the keyblade.
There you go.
Hey, come back.
What are you doing?
Don't you want to turn the key?
No, I don't want to turn the key.
Why not?
But dad does it again!
Makes fun for everybody.
See?
I'm here to make this a fun, enjoyable time for all the kids
to enjoy.
Oh, I think we have to go back.
Not here, but like back here.
Because there's another time thing here.
See that?
And then there's another one here too.
I think I have to do the wall thing here.
And then I do this.
Whoa.
Okay, and then I do this.
Isn't it great?
I can just sit back and relax.
Alright, and then...
Here you go.
And then...
Let me know when you're ready to do that.
Now you have to jump for this.
Oh, okay.
Okay, you ready?
Okay, I'm ready.
Yeah!
Fun Dad does it again!
There you go.
Let me know.
Boom!
And then...
Burn.
Wait till I get lower first?
YUM!
Yeah!
I know we did it.
Oh, what the fuck?
What happened?
I just died.
Remind it.
I was too close.
Wait, what?
I rewind it.
How do we...
Have to be under it?
No, that doesn't seem right.
Yeah.
It doesn't seem right.
How do we cut this?
Well, we cut it already.
Yeah, but how do we get inside?
Oh!
Wait, wait.
Bring him back up?
Yeah.
Oh!
You're so smart!
You're so smart.
Wife.
Stop!
Okay, there we go.
Bring him.
Wait.
Yeah.
We did it!
See?
Teamwork!
Fun dad, fun dad.
Let's go.
Alright.
What did... No, we...
Oh, do we have to turn it together?
Are that...
You think so, going?
No, like, we both have to turn one of it together, right?
Yeah, because I can't.
I'm too weak.
Fun dad is a little flabby.
Oh!
Where do we...
The key, is this the key?
Oh, and then we...
The other one turns it down.
Alright, here we go.
Can we do this?
Yay!
Oh, shit.
We did it!
Who the fuck's making this shit?
How...
We just...
We haven't even finished one chapter yet, I feel like.
We finished the princess cutie chapter.
That was a chapter?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
What is that?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
How do we kill this?
Wait, wait, wait.
There's a time in here.
Distract him.
I don't think the ball cares, Cody.
Oh!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I need you to lead the ball right here.
Lead him right here.
here i think maybe you can trick him with your clone yeah
trick him with your clone that stone plate looks like it
could hurt it yeah is he gonna go there oh it's gonna charge
wait what where are you charging oh me me oh fuck
I'm dead.
Bro, what the fuck?
Okay, oh, I don't have to be next to it to do this.
Put your clone!
Put your clone over there!
Oh, fuck!
It's me again.
Okay.
You have to put your clone over there.
Stoogie!
Shut up!
Watch out, mate!
Wimpy!
Okay.
It's okay, he's distracted.
I got it.
He doesn't see me.
Yeah!
We got him!
We did it!
I got it.
He doesn't see me.
Guys, I don't think he saw me.
Ow.
It's okay he didn't see me.
I can stand here.
Yeah!
Wait, what?
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Ow, it's fine.
Give me a second.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
He doesn't see me.
Here you go.
I can stand here.
Yay!
Bow down!
He could stand?
That should have done it!
Wow, okay.
Oh, I got body stabbed.
Why me?
What did I do?
Don't come near me.
I'm not ready!
Don't come near me!
I can't even steal!
I did it.
I mean, it's okay.
Thank you for the bait.
You're pissing me off.
You're like, leave the club there!
I did it.
It's a tough one.
Oh, I'm exhausted.
Yeah.
We better keep moving.
Come on.
We did it.
I'm so proud of us.
Oh, God.
Yay.
So hard, I know, right?
Cody understands the hard work of this marriage.
I wonder if, like, do you know what?
Oh, you can.
But, like, why would you?
I think we have to watch watch jump this, right?
Do we?
Why else would, like...
I'm so confused.
Why is it like that?
Hello, wife.
I need to eat a thumbs.
I don't understand.
What is this?
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
I can do it.
Alright?
Alright.
That's why I don't think so.
What?
This doesn't make sense.
What the fuck do we do?
Okay, I gotta help you wall jump.
How do I help you wall jump though?
All right, Gumi, you ready?
Uh-huh.
Oh!
I get it!
I have to- Stop moving it!
I'm okay!
Give it closer to you, see?
I'm making it close.
I'm making this easier for you.
Yay!
You make...
Fun dad, fun dad.
I want a divorce immediately.
Oh.
Oh, I gotta stand up here and then go We're...
We're...
Fun Dad's coming over!
Here I am!
Here we go.
We did it!
I think I have to...
I think, um...
But...
Hey, I think you have to come back here.
Why?
I need you to stand on the button So I can put my clone
there And stand on the button so you can get over So we both
can get...
Oh!
Wait, you're not Over?
I can't!
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
Don't worry.
Daddy's coming over.
Because daddy's Home.
Home for me.
Okay, now I can go.
Yay!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Look, there's- oh, we met up together, look!
We're back, we're okay now!
Now kiss.
Oh, what?
I don't have a good feeling about this.
Hey, what's this?
Please jump over?
Hey, you're supposed to calm me down.
I guess we just jump over.
What if I just...
Oh, don't stand in the center!
Don't stand on the center!
I don't think I was planning on it.
It's Mario Party.
It's the jump rope.
Watch this 360.
Is this hot?
Weeer.
Oh!
No!
Wait, you died?
The chest is not even soft there.
What the fuck?
I was relying on you to say a lie.
so I can fuck around.
But look at this 360 there.
Wow.
That 360 sucks.
Hey, I'm good.
I'm okay.
Let's go.
Yay.
360, no, let's go.
Oh, thank you, Gumi.
I'm like a poker stick.
I can't wait for the divorce papers to go.
Come through.
Thank you, Gumi.
I know I'm doing really well.
Oh, yeah.
Guys, I'm so...
I'm what the kids say.
Pog.
Ew!
I learned that on the tiki talk yesterday.
You hear about the...
there's like i was watching this video about this dad that's
like some fucking skateboarder some some shit some extreme
fucking no break dancer yeah this guy left his family to be
a professional break dancer oh my god yeah yeah and he like
makes really cringy tiktoks and shit I was watching like a
video like about talking about this fucking dad that was
like a professional break dancer and he left his family in
his career because he wanted to be a professional break
dancer and he's like 50 or some shit where do I go?
Sounds like you Oh they got a divorce?
Oh my god they got a divorce just to be a professional goals
but not really I'm gonna be us baby breakdancing yeah wait
his daughter lied mom can I stay with you dad is be cringe
yeah wait but the daughter lied for he paid millions in the
divorce oh my god but didn't he okay but like did he want
divorce because of breakdancing or because of or just
because he hates his wife like like which one is a does he
hate his wife or like he wanted to be a breakdancing.
He was a great dad.
He was and only took breakdance 20 years.
It's just a hobby.
The wife was bad.
Okay.
Damn, I can't believe the daughter lied on the internet on
TikTok.
I don't know what's going on, man.
The mom divorced him?
I don't want to know.
I just want to get out of here.
No, wait, I can't believe the daughter lied.
I can't believe it.
Anyway, I can't believe I lied on the internet.
I'm still fucking, like...
I'm still, like, registering the fact that...
The daughter lied about his break...
Her break dancing dad.
I don't know what's going on.
I haven't seen the break dancing dad, man.
Bro, he was on, like, America's Got Talent!
I don't know if he actually was on America's Got Talent.
But he apparently freaked out professionally.
Whoa, bird!
Once again, we're running out of real estate.
I can't believe it.
People lie on TikTok like that.
that i'm still registering the fact that brick dancing dad
was never brick dancing dad story was a lie he's a really
good break dancer you should look him up i'm not going to
look up break dancing dad why not he's a good he won like
trophies you just don't like dads in general are you talking
to me you don't like fun dads you i took hip-hop dance
classes and cars You just don't like fun, Dads.
You're right.
Because I think they're overcompensating for something.
It's not actual fun, it's fake fun.
It's fun!
Everybody enjoys jokey, Dad!
Not everyone.
This is why this marriage will never be.
work you don't appreciate fun dad I think that's why I
wanted to force in the first place you used to like fun dad
you used to love it what happened I don't think I ever liked
fun dad you only became a dad after we had a kid man you
used to love fun dad it was so fun there was nothing we just
like we're just like we go oh we can just stand in the
center I like how we just move like a little bit
yeah we don't have to like move too far which is nice I
think they really wanted us to stress out this game we did
it yay Luigi wins by doing nothing oh well down we go oh
it's like the the Disneyland like the the tower hotel tower
thing oh dude I hated that ride I never got to ride it I was
too young I haven't been in Disneyland in so fucking long
you want to go which one though I'm thinking I'm thinking We
can get a...
Well...
Which one's the best one?
I wanna go to Tokyo Sea.
I know... Okay, I actually... I'm not... I don't know,
because like Tokyo Sea, I've actually been to Tokyo Sea, but
I was like 10 or some shit.
What is happening?
We're rewinding, but to do this again?
I like how we're just having a casual conversation while we
do this.
Well, when did you want to take our trip together?
Oh yeah, we're supposed to... Are we going to Japan
together?
Or wait, where?
Do you want to go?
I'm down?
Did one of the...
I want to get Universal...
Message you a date.
I want to do, like, Universal Studios, though.
I feel like I've never been to...
I've only been to Universal Studio once, and it was for,
like...
Oh, I think we have to do the clock, right?
Yeah, we have to destroy the clock.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got this one.
Okay, last one.
The floor.
Okay, to be fair, Disney Night in general cost a lot of
money for no...
Oh no, yeah, it definitely does.
They're like, uh, they're like so excited.
I want to, okay, you know what I really want?
I want to do Universal Japan in Halloween.
Because like, I heard Halloween.
No, I actually wanted to go in October.
I hear like Halloween Universal Japan is like really, really
fun.
Really?
Yeah.
With all the ghosties?
Yeah, because like, it's like super creative, like their
costumes.
to help you oh we have to oh i think you um
you go on the side and then and then and then we go to here
and you have to do that where's the other one oh there it is
i'm very slowly going down Oh, behind you.
And then...
Where does this go?
I already turned it the most it can turn.
Turn it backwards.
Oh, there it is.
There is your back.
No, I don't think so.
Is it not?
Because I didn't...
Bring it...
Oh, no.
No!
You went!
How was I supposed to know?
Because I was supposed to stay on it!
Oh, no.
Okay.
Hello?
I hate this slow-motion jump.
I'm gonna fall soon!
Oh, no.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
Oh, there it is.
I do not have much time left.
Oh, there's something in front of you in front of you.
I know, I know the camera keeps automatically turning.
Oh, oh!
Goodbye, cruel world.
Goodbye.
Where are you now?
Did I go to this one?
I don't know.
Is this one or this one?
Is that one?
Stop turning my camera!
I'm not doing anything!
I'm not talking to you!
Apparently you went backwards.
What?
Here?
Okay.
This has to be the right way, yeah?
Oh, there it is.
Why can't we?
I'm so fucking dead.
There's no way I'm gonna live through this.
There's something below you.
This?
Is this everything?
Where, though?
Are you really almost there, though?
Like...
What happened?
Why would you build it?
What did you
do?
Goodbye.
Goodbye, Koura.
I don't know.
I've tried to take you so...
Where are you?
Do I move you or what?
There's a one here.
There's one here.
That's not going backwards, is it?
I don't know.
I can't tell anymore.
I feel like it is.
But maybe it's not.
I can't tell anymore.
I can't tell.
This one is the one that goes up.
Are you going backwards?
I can't tell.
Okay.
No, no, no, this here.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That thingy.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
Okay, wait.
Wait, you're going...
Are you going backwards?
I can't tell.
I think you are.
No!
Oh, you're not.
Okay.
Okay, we're okay, guys.
Everything is fine.
Oh, okay.
Why can't we be friends?
friends why can't we be friends that is i jump onto the
clock i guess so try oh i can jump on the glass oh thank god
oh okay i'm okay now dude why did you get the easiest part
yay
Yeah, everything always goes for Cody!
Yay, team Cody!
Let's go!
I love being Cody.
What is going on?
What the fuck are we doing?
What the fuck?
Equal distribution of effort.
Team Cody!
I think I need a nap I think I need a nap after this You
like slept at 5 We supposed to slept at 5 I know But it's
funny I'm doing a 16 hour stream Oh yeah Because you're
doing like TFT and also Minecraft later Whoa Hey there girl
Maybe I will take a nap after this game We're insane out
chemistry what oh god hey you're gonna keep up your end of
the bargain mr book of truth uh-huh okay okay that's the way
you want to go uh-huh okay you like it yeah okay yeah Ew.
Okay, let's do it!
What happened to our legs at first?
Wait, we're in a clock.
Why was there like a house in this clock?
Dude, imagine being rose and your house is slowly falling
apart and your parents won't wake the fuck up.
Like, who's gonna be making dinner?
It's working!
Our cuckoo clock is working again!
That's nice, sweetie.
Kazu leave me alone Mommy had too much fixy juice So she
needs to sleep now What the fuck Rose Get the fuck down from
there Yes a clock
That's it What the fuck Oh hey it's another therapy session
Dear mom Notice I'm first Yeah but she blames She's a dear
mom and she blames it on herself.
A child.
Tell me we don't have to go through four of these sieges.
Attraction!
Oh god.
We don't need attraction.
We're getting divorced.
Aha!
That's because you lost it.
But don't worry.
I'll help you find attraction again.
Oh god.
Dude, get this guy off my screen.
This is abuse.
This is tortured.
Let me out.
You can't force someone to like each other again.
Holy shit.
Oh, it's a snow level.
I've seen this level.
I did not think this game was this long.
I told you it was a 14 plus hour game.
What do you mean?
Dude, I thought that's because people try to get, like,
every secret.
some shit.
Attraction is like a magnet, but you need both poles.
No, Sal, plus, minus.
Cody, Meg.
I'm the plus.
No, he said plus, minus.
One is plus, one is minus.
Oh.
That's not how it works.
Red is minus, blue is plus.
Who gets blue?
It's me.
What?
Oh, I'm the plus.
I got.
And when a negative plus a negative comes together, it makes
me positive.
Okay, well, we don't have two negatives.
We have a positive and a negative.
The negative comes together.
Yes.
This is where we had our first skiing trip together.
Oh my god.
The two first skiing trips.
That's us.
What the stuff?
Oh, it's a snow globe.
We're stuck inside that snow globe we bought there.
Get to the top of the mountain to receive your next piece of
the letter.
Yeah, what if we freeze to death trying to get there?
Use your magnet powers and the attraction will warm you up,
baby.
Oh, God.
She did not need to...
Is he like humping the snow globe?
He did not need to do that.
I'm going to break the snow globe the moment we get out.
It's compromised.
That was so freaking gross.
That was pretty gross.
Yeah.
Guys, how much do we have left from this game?
I sure hope so.
Wait, what?
Get stuck.
Let me try.
He he.
You're not blue, man.
Wait, why can't you open it anymore?
Oh, it's because of me.
Wait, how do I do this?
I did it!
You're welcome, Malini.
Oh, God.
We have four!
Oh, we have four.
Okay, you want LG this level?
All right, nice.
Yeah, I'll go fuck myself, I guess.
Wait, what?
Do you need me?
I can't do anything here.
Oh, I can.
I'll leave this one for you.
All right, nice.
Oh, like usual.
Yay!
What a team.
Wait, is there something we should do?
Oh!
I'm red.
What the?
It launched me.
Wait, what?
Where am I?
Ready?
What are you doing?
What the hell?
It launched me off?
And then it like...
What?
Okay.
Alright, and then I push this.
Can I not push this?
What am I supposed to do?
Let me...
Oh, you do it!
But it was red!
Okay, you do it.
Because...
Oh!
Yeah, but I'm red.
And now I do this.
Don't leave me here, Cody!
Help me get over!
Let me go.
I'm doing it.
Team work!
Oh, because it's blue and I'm red and with magnets.
And then the...
I just learned how to use magnets.
I just learned how to use magnets, guys.
I'm learning!
See, every day I learned something new.
Every day.
Hey, remember our first Christmas with Rose?
You mean when all the Christmas trees were sold out?
Yeah.
We snuck into the woods and cut down one ourselves.
Guys, how do they work?
When you have two of the same color, you push them away.
But when you have like opposite colors, you pull them in.
Kumi should have taught me this instead of me figuring it
out.
So opposites attract.
But if you have two of the same kind, do we tell each other?
Yeah!
Opposite works as well.
Oh, so it'll push me up.
Because opposite same thing, people push each other away.
Okay.
It's me, because I'm red.
And what do you do?
I need you to pull that to...
I need you to pull that, isn't it?
I feel like you have to pull it.
I can't pull it.
Yeah, I don't reach it.
Oh, wait.
There's something else here.
Oh, there's something else here.
You're supposed to pull that.
Yo!
I think I have to pull it all the way.
I'm pretty sure.
Stop!
There we go.
And then...
And then I pull this.
See?
I pull this.
And then you go in.
And I launch you.
And then you do that.
And then I can pull it now.
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
You gotta push it more.
It just barely got on my hands.
I got it.
Yay.
I'm coming over, my love.
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up, man.
I gave you my love.
And the very next day...
You gave it up.
You pushed me away.
Okay.
Don't leave me.
You can't run away from this handsome, hunk of a man
forever.
Ew!
I
am a catch, okay.
I am a 10 out of 10.
Dude, any guy who tells you that...
I'm a catch!
I'm a 10 out of 10!
No, I'm different!
Okay, that one's off.
There, here, I gave it to you.
I literally gave you the thing.
Why are you pulling that way?
Because you need to get the blue!
Do you get closer?
Oh, wait.
Yeah, you need to get the...
Blue repels.
No.
Yeah.
I learned magnets.
I know how magnet works.
Yeah.
Oh, you're a thingy.
A lot.
A thingy.
Go for it.
Why did you do that?
I'm helping!
Go!
Wait, why did you get back?
How did you get back?
I was trying to launch off of it!
All right, go, go.
Go for your blue.
There you go.
See?
Chat, am I a 10 out of 10?
Any wife would be happy to have me.
Right?
Anybody would want me as a husband.
See, look at all the people that said yes, and look at all
the people I ignored that said something else.
That said something else.
Clearly, the other thing did not matter.
Damn, 100% people thought I am a catch.
Wee!
Fast travel.
What's this?
Oh, yes!
Okay, helping.
I'm helping.
Wait, how do we...
We have to do...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
I got it!
Oh, where am I?
You have to go to that...
You see that other blue thing?
You have to go there.
There's a blue thing over there.
Wait, where are you?
Where did I go?
You literally went backwards.
I got launched.
Wait, have you died?
Maybe you'll respond next to me.
You think so?
Yeah.
Oh, my leg.
Oh.
Yeah, see?
You're next to it.
Yo.
Weaning.
No.
Go.
You have to.
There's a blue thing over there on the other side.
What do you mean?
No.
Oh.
Get off.
I did.
No.
What do you mean?
That's how you do it.
Do I?
The blue thing repels, no?
I repel it.
No, you have to...
You get on, and then you get to that blue.
Is that blue over there?
Yeah, and then I repel the blue, because I repel it.
Wait, huh?
Then how do we do this?
Then you do it
Yeah, you do it.
How do you do it?
I have to pull this over here.
I guess so.
Oh, oh, what if I like bring it to you?
Push it a little.
Yeah, I bring it to you and then you do.
Oh my god, we're so smart We know magnets.
Why did you keep telling me to go get pulled by blue when
you know why are you jumping?
what that was.
I thought it was a box.
Oh, God.
I got to go to sleep.
I think you're right.
We're rekindling our love.
Oh, my God.
Do I have anything in my pants?
What?
We're rekindling our love.
You know what we're gonna do you know what will fix our
marriage another kid Maybe we just we just We just have two
little kids Dude, I feel like that's actually how some
married couples think I fucking another child will fix this
we just need a baby in the house I miss when your boobies
were bigger because we had a baby
Dude, I read a post like that recently that I was like, Am I
the asshole for wanting my wife to be pregnant Because her
boobs are bigger?
That's real?
I'm pretty sure it's a meetup post.
That I can't, yeah, no man would fucking write that.
Oh my god.
There's no way I actually wrote that.
That's so good.
There's a guy who...
There has to be a joke.
It was a real life story, but the guy was like, my name is
Jarman, and boy do I love breast milk.
No, but that's a thing.
That's a real, like, fetish.
Yeah, but, like, then people probably...
Some men do feel that way.
Yeah.
You understand.
What?
some people are ass man and some people are boobs some
people like butts and some like boobs i understand are we
going in the right okay pull the fucking door man yeah sorry
mommy sorry mommy sorry so i was like did you read my bio
yeah i get it pussy and bio like there are some people are
the front some people are the backs what's happened here
used to be so busy i know where is everyone and sometimes
both where are they it's down used to be like your
relationship alive and fun but look at it now silent dead
frozen you need to wake it up from its winter sleep how are
we gonna do that charlie did not have to tell me though you
like it smaller So I was like, please do not conflate breast
appreciators with milk.
Yes.
The two are completely different schools of thought.
What did they say?
They're like, please don't group us together with those who
like milk.
We're just going to get crazy ideas.
Oh my god.
Bro.
And some people like Thaz.
The ancient ninja rivalry.
But is it me?
I don't know.
Am I supposed to push it?
Oh, I think you pull it.
Yeah, it's me.
Then you have to press this button.
Wait, what?
What?
This opens something.
Right?
It lifts this rock up, but...
But, like, what does that do?
Confused.
What are you supposed to do here?
Oh!
Wait, am I supposed to watch him?
Oh, can I pull it even further?
Wait, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
I can pull it?
Oh, I can pull it.
further.
Oh.
Why do you keep doing this?
Time learning.
It goes nothing.
More and more I learn every day.
Ooh.
I learn more and more every day.
Why do you doing this why why did you do this what do you
mean oh my god they're alive killed it oh my god they're
like the ice king from adventure time they're like mini ice
it reminded me of this guy from um the island from mario
sunshine oh yeah but with clothes on we did good we did this
oh my god they're
Do you remember it like this, you freak?
That's you.
Oh my god, look at her back.
You're calling yourself a freak.
Oh, that's so cute.
Why are you calling yourself a freak?
Hey, we got to open the door.
We got to open that door.
I'm my, my,
my, oh, that's so pretty.
Can you host another poll?
Why?
Who, um, what's the poll?
Who?
What was, what was the poll?
did last time who's the reason for it a divorce no no the
the other poll was like am i am i a 10 out of 10 catch you
know i would yeah i'm gonna write that am i am i a 10 out of
10 uh oh i'm
catch of a husband.
There we go.
That's my pull.
I got fixed myself because I'm big again.
I accidentally went big.
Give me a sec.
No, I'm big.
What the fuck?
What did I do?
Oh my god, what did I do?
Okay.
There we go.
Big.
Not big anymore.
Hold on, I need to vote real quick.
Wait, what do you mean?
Why do you need a vote?
Because we're the one that's...
I'm literally married to you.
What?
Why do you need a vote?
I don't understand.
Look, see?
More people think I'm a catch!
And then the other's opinions don't matter.
so it's a hundred percent right it's a hundred percent i
knew it i knew it i knew it i think this is how men egos
inflate what do you mean i just saw it in real time what the
fuck do you mean i'm a 10 out of 10 What?
You're the worst husband of I've ever been married to.
You had multiple husbands?
I thought you had multiple wives, not husbands.
Hey, man.
Have you seen 707 from Mystic Messenger?
Damn.
You know what?
I don't know.
This is exactly why I'm getting a divorce.
I'm going to find somebody that's going to appreciate me as
a husband.
What do I do here?
I don't know.
Launch off of it.
But what am I throwing?
This?
Oh, I'm giving you magnets!
Take it.
Did you fall?
What are you doing?
You see, my new wife is gonna figure this out faster.
I'm not doing puzzles for us.
anymore
It's fucked up What the fuck?
You do puzzles by yourself now What are you doing?
Go fucking get the magnet You can leave when we're people
again I don't want to fall
There ya, you're welcome You're lucky You're lucky I don't
hold grudges I'm getting like actual war flashback
Fun dad Fun dad, fun dad Fun dad Fun dad's here Oh god I
think I did all my stuff Fun dad Fun dad Run that!
Oh god, I just...
I just had a PTSD moment.
What hours?
I think I need to cut my hair.
What?
Where do we go from the hours?
Wow, this place has great energy.
Whoa, it's so beautiful!
I want to go to the other tower.
hair are you pulling a mulan
could be okay
guys i don't know where it's gonna happen was it me no it
can't be me i can never be the issue
Goomy.
Goomy, I need help.
Goomy, I'm on the other side.
Where are you, Goomy?
Get on the owl!
I just cut off three locks in my hair.
Oh, no.
What happened?
We're over.
Did you... Did you overdose on the fun?
Did you just have too much fun?
I understand.
No, I don't think so.
Get on the owls and go on the other side.
I'm on the other side of the tower.
Like, really other side.
Oh, hey, Snowball.
Oh, I'm gonna get you.
I think you're back to being wife number four.
I was always wife number four.
You got promoted to wife number two.
Do you know what?
Now you're wife number five.
What?
Why did I get a new one?
What did I do?
Say that again.
Gonna be back in my white spot right now.
Okay, for both of us, we need...
We need to do the puzzle!
Give it a puzzle!
You can't hold a hot ass robot forever.
Alright, I can grab more.
Come on.
Oh my god, do it a puzzle!
I got homing missiles.
This is fucked up.
Then, what do I have to do?
Wallchup, man.
Oh, here.
I couldn't tell where the walls were.
What do you mean?
I can hold on to this for just a little bit.
I don't think you have to pull.
Let go.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, now let go.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Stay?
Yeah.
Oh, you don't let go.
Oh, whoops.
Do you do that again?
Fun dad, fun dad, yeah.
Fun dad's here.
Fun dad, fun dad.
I'm so fun.
Oh!
Why did you...
I had to do that again.
Don't worry.
That means more time for fun dad.
Come on.
Get me out of here.
More time to spend for fun dad.
Yay!
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Longer time before that.
Yay!
Woo!
Okay, I'm ready.
You have to take me to the other side again.
Nice.
I'm here.
Yeah!
Oh, God.
We did it!
Handcake!
Oh my God, there's food!
Can I have- can I borrow like $5?
No!
You're right.
We have- we share a bank account.
I already cut you off from- It's okay.
We share a bank account.
It's okay.
I moved all the funds back to my personal bank account.
Wait, that's so fucked up!
You can't do that legally!
We're getting divorced.
We can't.
We're getting.
We're not divorced yet.
Out here?
I don't trust you with fun.
What do you mean?
Don't trust my fun.
I'm so fun.
We have to head to the other tower.
I'm at the other tower.
Hi.
We gotta free these guys.
Free these nuts.
The big wheels turning.
Oh, wait.
Get over here.
Fun Dad's waiting for the fun.
Bad move.
Yeah, if you do that, my lawyer has a case for me.
We signed a prenup.
No, I did and I forgot to sign it.
No, you have to go to the other...
Oh, wait, no, I have to.
Wait, no, you have to because of tracks.
Alright, what do you have to do now?
You need to turn it.
I turn, I turn, I turn.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, keep turning.
I turn.
Here I am.
I'm here now.
Yay!
I did it!
I'm up.
And then...
Okay.
Oh my god, we're so smart.
This is why we're perfect for each other.
You have to pull this?
What does the opposite to track mean?
Yeah, so you pull it down.
Get on the freaking thing.
I didn't know that...
I didn't know that I was on the elevator.
I didn't...
I didn't know it was an elevator!
Get on the freaking thing.
Context clues!
Where are my explicit context clues?
Oh, there's a fence wheel!
Hey, hey, it looks like that gondola lift is working.
Hurry, let's catch it.
There's a gondola lift?
Yeah, over here.
Oh, it's over there!
We go to the gondola!
Whoa, this guy is huge.
Whoa!
Wait, I can, like, make this go fast.
That's the king right, have fun!
Dude, I love those rides.
I love those rides at a carnival.
Fun forever!
That's right, you're all gonna have fun forever!
What the hell?
I'm going to the gondola.
How do you get to the gondola?
Opposite attract.
Wait, it won't let me get on.
How do I- Oh, there it is!
Are you okay?
Yeah, that was me stretching.
I'm heading out.
I'm getting there.
Don't worry.
The gondola's working.
It's a ferris wheel, man.
No, it's a gondola!
See?
And then...
Why didn't you want to go on the ferris wheel with me?
And then we go down there.
Because you tried to beat my ass with snowballs.
Yay!
You started it!
What?
Hey, an aquarium!
Yeah, that's right, I said it.
How do we turn this?
How did you get it?
Oh, there's how you get in there.
I'm pushing.
Why aren't you pushing?
Fun?
Dad?
Dude, the thing is my character won't move.
Wait, why are you stuck?
Just kidding.
I'm moving now.
Look, this is a gondola, okay?
Oh, so that's a mini gondola.
We made it.
It's a minigun, right?
My ears are still ringing.
Why didn't you want to do the fairy spiel with me?
It's romantic.
Me too.
That's the shop where I got your Christmas gift.
Get away from me.
What do you mean?
We're husband and wife.
Before we got here.
I wanted a boy.
Get away from me.
Give daddy a kiss.
No!
I can't fit it in my Christmas presents.
You still like it.
What happened to the Christmas?
You still like this.
I don't want a kiss.
Run, go on here.
We can fix this marriage if we just give each other a little
kiss.
I don't want a kiss.
That's a party.
I'm taking his hat.
Oh, look at me!
I have this hat!
This one fits perfectly.
I haven't.
Look at my hat.
I'm not compensating for anything.
I just think it's a really nice hat.
Sad for another child that thinks our marriage.
Why is this guy?
Oh my god, look at this guy.
He's T-posing.
Look at him.
Oh, look at him.
Oh, we're gonna be bobsledding.
Hey, Cody.
Nice hat.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, nice hat.
That's right.
I'm a better button masher.
Can we review the second game?
Woo!
So give me go.
Yeah.
Dad's winning.
Because I know how to have fun.
Let me go.
I want to take a napie.
Oh, no, I missed.
I missed the ride.
Didn't see it.
Okay, nice.
We're going.
I have racing games experience.
are we we're like in a tunnel it's a tunnel what are we in
oh my god is that fish oh we're in a fish now we're in a
fucking fish yeah yeah yeah yeah that is oh i am i'm moving
dick oh why is it so bloody god is he dead is he dead or is
he alive oh he's definitely dead why do you mean is it alive
that's there that's outside i don't know maybe he's sleeping
could be sleeping you know that hibernation wait that's so
weird i'm ahead on my screen but yeah i'm good earlier what
no i'm still ahead he's just hibernating like bears did you
know bears don't actually hibernate that's what's just yeah
i know you knew we made that up to tell kids i blame
spongebob i don't believe it i learned that yesterday bears
don't hibernate we did a poll and um they voted on who's
more dependent on the other you won congratulations wait on
your poll come on uh-huh
It just means I won't make this marriage to work.
It means I put more effort in trying to fix this marriage.
No, it means you're more dependent on my mind.
It means I'm trying.
He has killed many the surface.
I need it.
And I need it.
Water level?
That looks chilly.
I don't do well in cold water.
No, not water level.
Should we put the water level for next time?
No!
I don't want to do water level.
We have to finish this chapter out.
Not the water level.
Where do I go?
I'm already lost.
I'll have to go to you.
I wonder how it'll help us get to the top of the island.
What is that machine?
Okay.
Everyone loves water levels.
Music is so good usually.
It's the music that's good, but the gameplay fucking sucks.
Except the Pokemon games.
That's not really a water level, though.
What is this?
I don't know.
Dude, I kind of missed this, like, old Pokemon games where
you could, like, deep dive into the scene.
Oh, yeah.
I know what we're talking about.
Yeah.
The one when you go to ruins and stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, he angie.
Do you imagine being this whack-ass book where you created
these characters and you pretend to talk to them?
He's just like me.
He's writing his own story.
He has no one else to talk to, so he makes up imaginary
friends.
Yeah, just like me in fourth grade.
But you also, like, hump snow globes, too.
Like him?
No.
but i will say no never mind i don't want to say okay don't
tell me we're just going to bring the sweetness back into
our relationship of course without sweetness a relationship
will die you hear that without sweetness the relationship
will die oh you say something i was opening a rice cracker
we need a senbei well and where have you shown me some
appreciation for working overtime to support the family
right now well there was that time when we thanks for
working overtime i did it on the candy production and make
the sweetness blow again hope you packed your toolkit what
the hell Damn, why am I so bitter?
No, water, the fuck.
Oh,
there's some fishies.
There's a leak here.
We need to fix it somehow.
How do we fix it?
Help me with this wrench, Cody.
here
wait what it's turning it's turning what do we do I refuse
to be fish
wait what do we do oh
help me help me help me where are you where are you oh there
you are Okay, I get it.
Oh!
Oh,
I'm stuck.
Where am I?
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
I think I just lost a few years there.
I'm hoping.
Where do we pull it to?
Where are we pulling it to?
Nothing.
No, that.
I'm pulling it.
Where are you pulling it to?
I'm pulling it to you.
My beautiful wife.
See?
I did my job.
And then we...
Where do we push it to?
Riding tidy, righty tidy, turn it, turn it.
I'm turning it.
Are we doing the wrong one?
I'm scared.
Is he coming?
I don't think so.
Maybe it's the other way.
Is it the other way?
Yeah, it was... You pulled the wrong way!
Ready, tidy!
Alright, nice.
I gotta go to the other one.
I got it.
Oh!
It can't eat all of us!
Wait, why did you let go?
What do you mean, why did I let go?
Why did you let go?
Pull it!
Please, I'm so weak!
You didn't marry me for my beautiful body Or maybe you did
You just into the Once again Arrangement My parents lost a
bet Yes but then The more you spent time with me The more
you fell in love with me It's like beauty and the beast I'm
beauty Beauty and a beast We can make it Complete Right way
Right way Oh, we did it.
Okay, one more.
Where'd you go?
Where's the last one?
Oh!
I'm dead.
By the way, wait, I'm alive.
Wait, where do we?
Where's the last one?
Wait, the last one's behind.
I see it.
I see where it is.
I'm heading over.
It's this way behind.
oh my gosh I know I'm just waiting I'm heading over I'm
heading over to make my mind come please oh shit it's okay
it didn't get me dodged yeah gotta go up Bring it up.
Bring it up.
It's stuck in there here.
Alright.
Nice.
Twisty turny.
Yeah!
We fixed it.
Hey, it's working!
Look at that casting!
Mom.
I'm going to do one more.
Two more?
Wait, how do we get out of here?
Wait, no, that's the machine.
Oh, it's backwards.
It's backwards.
Went the wrong way.
Oh.
That's right.
That's why you have me.
I know where I'm going.
Somehow you give me the ick more and more each line you say.
everything every line you say gives me the egg what i am
trying so hard to help us here i am trying my heart yeah
maybe you should stop trying my heart is right now you
should stop trying don't appreciate me maybe maybe it's time
to give it a break where do we go here
What is this, aren't we?
Like, where are you?
Maybe this way?
Oh, it's this way!
I figured it out.
It's here.
This is a swordfish.
I wait.
Oh, the fuck?
Whoa!
and down we need to oh wait we have to make my life come we
gotta make sure we don't die to that okay oh it's like only
one of us makes it through that's all that matters right
okay wait no I meant like me what yeah you make it through
no I meant I meant like I have the privilege to die okay
your turn
Okay, thank you.
Okay, here we go.
I'm coming over.
Doki does have negative Riz.
I don't know how.
How do I have negative Riz?
63% the majority people voted that, that, like, I'm 10 out
of 10.
I don't understand.
How do we get out of here?
I'm like stuck in the water.
What?
Oh!
I see it.
At least I don't feel cold because I'm a doll.
Yay!
I pressed the wrong button.
Okay, here we go.
What the fuck?
I keep pressing the wrong button.
Do you need me over there?
Nice.
I made it.
What the hell?
I'll show you how it's done.
Okay, I'll show you how it's done.
Okay, can you press the wrong button again?
No, it's okay.
I learned how to do it.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, that's so cool.
Okay.
Ow.
Don't worry.
I'll grab the checkpoint so you can just fall next to me.
Oh, thank you.
Don't worry.
Your boo's got it.
Did you just call me?
Or call yourself my boo?
That's something else.
What do you mean?
We're married!
There's something else.
That is called the Doki Riz.
She liked it, guys.
I think she liked it.
I felt like that was the equivalent to some random guy at
the bar saying, Hey, what's up, Shwadi?
She liked it, guys.
What do we do here?
Oh, you have to push and then I push and then you push.
Let's go.
What are you doing correctly?
We are.
Yeah, you miss all the shots you don't shoot.
Eventually something will...
Hey, but sometimes you should shoot your shot.
Sometimes, like, you have to hit it all.
You have to keep going until it hits.
Look at that pep.
Were we supposed to jump up there?
Only one more to go.
Yeah, up here.
Weeeee!
Where do we how do we get back though Oh Oh you didn't tell
me press x you can go faster Wee They taught you that at the
very beginning Ice race let's go Okay green Green pass
through the Complete a lap I got this chat watch this But
like if I don't got this don't watch Watch.
Oh no.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
What the fuck?
That's okay.
Woo.
I'm so fucking right.
Yeah!
I'm so fucking fast!
That's crazy.
I didn't know you can take the rings in front of me.
So when I went...
You would take it.
It's like the Mario Kart item.
Should have been so slow.
If you were a little faster, then you could have taken these
rings.
Yeah, and that's why I'm divorcing you because you go a
little too fast.
Whoa!
What the fuck in front of everybody?
They had to know the truth.
I thought I thought we were keeping that private.
I thought we were keeping that private
Some people like that You know that yeah, honestly my new
wife would love it I'm planning
Yes I think you're right You're a sore loser You're a sore
loser Loser Yeah, I'm just gonna say it you're a sore loser.
Wait, how did you win?
What?
I won.
Wait, what?
I followed the path properly.
What?
I think I got more rings than you.
How did you win?
I got more rings than you.
I'm missing check.
I'm apparently missing check boy.
What?
I didn't even realize I can't, I went too fast.
I went.
That's what I'm saying.
I can't believe you can actually go too fast.
That's so fucked up.
I can't believe it.
Everything's a lie.
Everything's a fucking lie.
One day you'll learn your lesson.
Today might not be that day.
That's how the candy factory is connected to the lighthouse.
I'm so sad.
I need a fucking head to bed and listen to some Lincoln
Park.
There we go.
Here?
Oh, it's back here.
Where's the last one, though?
Which one do we do already?
I can't tell.
Everything looks the same.
Which one are we missing?
This one.
Oh, it's this one.
We follow this pipe.
I see it.
I feel so empty inside.
Okay.
I feel so empty.
Alright.
I don't have the seabat rhythm!
What do you mean?
That's a good rhythm anyway.
You guys are just fucking...
What the fuck are you?
I don't know.
How did you get there?
How do you get in there?
What the fuck?
I'm so confused.
Where are you?
Oh, there you go.
you are figured it out what do you do you come here stay
right there okay I say here go pull the other side go pull
the other side I hope there's another side oh
there is wait there's no other side we're talking about I
think I have to find the hole.
I have experience with that.
Don't worry.
Watch this.
Wait.
Give me a second.
Oh, it's here!
It's here!
Wait, no.
No, wait.
Wait, Gumi, I need help.
What do I do, Gumi?
I need you to teach me.
What do I do?
I felt like you saw it.
I didn't.
What do I do?
Go find a hole.
But what if I can't find it?
Where is the hole?
Is it here?
No.
No, that's not.
Where is it?
This is a hole.
Hole?
Oh, maybe it's here.
If no, the hole is the goal.
Are you divorced yet?
I wish.
I'm here, but this is not open.
Hey, I think I need you to open this one for me.
Yeah, you need to open this.
Yeah, see?
I knew it wasn't me.
Oh, I can see the generator.
It's on the opposite side.
To be fair, I saw it earlier, but I wanted to see if you
would say something.
It's a group effort.
It's pretty warm in here.
Where do we have to take me to?
Here?
I don't think so, right?
Is it here?
Halfway there.
So where do we go from here?
Yeah, we're...
I don't think it's this way.
I think you have to go above.
You turn more or no?
What do we go from here?
here
oh yeah yeah there you go and then you turn i have to go
higher can i go higher now go higher i'm trying go higher
okay nice nice nice that's high enough
yeah i know it's a bit difficult to rely on me right now I
think I need to go to sleep.
I think I need to go to sleep.
I'm doing it!
Yeah!
I did it!
Yay!
Yippee!
Why do I feel like made just a lot of the heavy lifting?
I don't know.
I feel like I did an equal amount of work there.
Ah!
There's noign marriage.
Oh, God.
There is an I in marriage!
Did you notice that?
I've been saying that this entire stream, and you didn't
notice.
No, I didn't even say there's no I and I.
You didn't notice.
I said that the entire stream, and now you noticed.
No, the entire time you've been saying there's no.
No, I've been saying there's no I in Merritt's this entire
time.
I've been saying it this entire time.
And you never noticed until now.
It took you four hours to catch on.
I just block you out.
You say some shit like, oh, teamwork.
Look, teamwork.
I just block it out.
A marriage needs communication, Gumi.
You need a communication.
when you feel like it's too much.
I communicate to you, but you need to start listening to me.
How do you say something?
Push.
I think I need to go make another artichoke.
Oh, no!
What about your artichoke?
What?
I need to make it for a grandpa!
Is she left to make her artichoke?
artichoke i hope elise at the top of the mountain yeah so do
i i think she left to make her artichoke yep here we go it's
gonna be so romantic oh no goomy's not gonna be here to see
the romance blossom between us
yeah for crap but yeah we have earned it see we even the
game agreed this is teamwork i don't understand
you know we haven't been on vacation since rose was born
really has it been that long yep why did we stop going
skiing well rose was born because rose hates skiing the
bills piled up yeah yeah i guess she hates the snow in the
roof remember oh don't remind me Maybe once we sold the
house, there might be some money left over for a weekend
trip.
Timer for Falcon!
You could take Rose to Waterland.
Yeah, it's a great idea.
She's been bugging us all summer to take her there.
And then I'll take her again when it's my turn.
Yeah, she'll have to go twice.
Oh my god, we're talking about custody.
You say something?
We're talking about the custody.
You're gonna have full custody, right?
Let's race.
fun chat fun dad yeah yeah yeah but i come over like once
every once a week so like she'll she'll continue thinking
i'm fun because i only show up when it's fun time
sorry so it's like so like you know i can be like rose it's
time to go to the amusement park it's daddy's time the
sunday dad yeah the sunday dad exactly first time
So she'll always remember me as the fun one.
Woo!
It's Sundad.
Yeah, instead of Sunday, it's Sundad.
I figured it out.
Lame.
What do you mean lame?
You're just jealous because you're not the fun mom.
Yeah, and then I'm going to have a badass motorcycle and...
I'm gonna have my mid-life crisis And then Rose is gonna be
like Mom, why aren't you as fun as fun dad?
I'm going to dad's And then she's gonna see me in my In my
bachelor pad And it's gonna look so fucking sad And I'll be
like, Rose, what are you doing here?
Hey, it's not Sun Dad's day And she's gonna be like Yeah,
mom was mentioning me Can I live off your money and bills
now?
And then I was like sweetie we have an arrangement there's a
reason why i'm sun dad
oh my god what the fuck this guy this guy looks scary bro
he's chained up yeah i'm feeling we should yeah i don't know
yeah me too he's chained up for our reason why are you going
this way there's no way though i thought we can wall jump
this but there's no way to do
Oh, take him near.
Oh, wait, wait.
Take him over here.
Yeah, let me bring him.
That's too real.
I'm glad it's frozen.
But I'm fun.
At least I'll be fun.
I'm stuck.
I don't know how to put you out.
You don't pull.
You push.
Remember?
Push.
Stop pushing.
Yay!
Magnets!
Yeah!
I love magnets.
Help me, Stepdoki.
Oh my god, no, and then you're gonna get...
You're gonna... I'll be like the cool dad.
And then I fucked up.
Why did you...
I think you're supposed to...
No, it's because...
you're supposed to take me to the fish hooks over there.
I didn't fuck up.
I realized we fucked up together.
Because I was supposed to go to the fish hooks.
Yeah, and then when your mom remarries, when Gumi remarries,
you're gonna realize your stepdad is not as cool as me.
And I'm gonna show up with my badass motorcycle and I'll be
like, oh, is Jerry treating you okay?
Rose.
What's with you?
You're gonna name Jerry, man!
Hey!
Check out the hooks above!
I bet Jerry didn't bring you a pony!
Alright.
What is this?
Oh wait, no?
What do I do here?
Alright, pull this down?
What is this?
Many times don't have to teach you, old man.
You're not pulling nothing.
I'm a little confused.
How do you get here?
Did I...
Did I fuck something up?
No, I couldn't.
I'm smart.
No, you're supposed to come here.
I did a platform for you.
I made you this.
Look, I did this.
I did this.
You're welcome.
Shut up.
Yay!
Alright, and then you're supposed to do this one.
Right here.
No, right here.
Go next to me.
I thought you...
Yeah.
And then I jump over and you pull it.
Yay!
Yeah, we're doing it.
I'm using my brain.
I need a water break.
I'm using 1% of my brain.
This is it.
Bumi?
Ah.
My hand hurty.
Bumi?
Huh?
The hook?
No, the other one.
There's one to your right.
I don't think this is gonna move.
Yeah, this doesn't move.
It's okay.
I know you don't mean that.
Alright, nice.
Alright, move me to the other side.
Yay!
Say poobies.
Move me to the other side.
I don't need to say please, we're already married.
Gumi, I know you want this game to be over, so you have to
move me to the other side.
The longer you stay here, the longer we're going to be
playing this game.
You know, you can't avoid that.
There you go, I made it.
The longer you delay this, the longer we stay married.
Okay, here you go.
Oh my god, is that bones?
I'm glad to see you peek out about these things, but I just
hope they hold off.
Whose bones are these?
What the fuck is this?
In the f- Yeah, I know, in the cube!
Whose bones are these?
In the snow globe!
Yay!
I still can't believe I missed a checkpoint.
I still can't believe- What did you say?
I can't believe I missed a checkpoint in that race.
I can't believe it.
I got a little more checkpoints muted.
I thought it was all about going fast and being efficient.
It was all alive.
I'm still ahead.
I can't wait to eat another artichoke tonight.
No, you're not.
Wait, what the fuck?
How did you get the airtime?
Where did you get the airtime?
for this uh-huh it's okay i made it ahead a cabin yeah let's
see if they know the way to the top we're still not the top
oh god open the door of opportunity really oh when something
dies something new can be
you but your relationship what the hell with a p no relation
shit as in shit like kaka you need to reveal your
relationship into a why can't we just close the door on him
this guy just really like saying doesn't he yeah i wish we
could build a fire collapsed remember where something
something new can be built sharp then the attraction can
grow freely you know This is a PG question for Alicia.
I'm gonna shart.
Please, please stop.
I hope you shart your pants later.
Stop!
Shart yourself.
We are mature adults here.
We are...
We are mature people!
We do...
We do... We do very smart adult jobs.
Sharks here Shark thyself
What the fuck are you like dashing in front of me?
I'm trying to go as fast as I can
Look at that you're having fun almost dying that's fucked up
Great I'm here, you know what I'm saying you're like this
true spirit
You know, Tony Hawk is like almost, wait, he's like 60,
right?
That's actually crazy.
He's like somewhere in 50s or 60s now, and he's still
skateboarding.
That's gotta be me when I'm in my 60s.
That's a lie.
Dude, leave us alone.
Leave us alone.
This is creepy.
We can fix our relationship without you.
Thank you!
Oh god, we're getting magnetized.
Jesus, he's still shredding it at 55.
What the fuck are you doing?
How do we do this?
You're free now.
We can, like, body slam.
Indeed, the hole is greater than the parts.
The magnet's attraction is getting stronger.
Wait, what the fuck?
It's already choke time!
Wait, what?
What?
What the fuck?
Be a bat.
Gooby, what the fuck?
We're still in this game!
At least head over!
Oh my god.
We're so close to finishing this chapter.
We were so close.
We were almost there.
Oh
Artichoke over joking
Let me go Why did you pick artichoke?
They were so close we were so close to finishing this
chapter it was literally right there it was literally right
there oh my god it's okay guys one day we can finish this
trap there one day i put i believe in us i can't believe she
picked an artichoke over me i don't understand again i get a
ride i don't understand But I'm Doki.
Look at me.
Look at this.
And I fucking love artichokes.
I can't believe it.
All right.
If I was dangling off a cliff.
But there's an artichoke next to you.
Huh?
Get over here.
Whoops.
Sorry, I went the wrong way.
You jump to me.
You attract over yet, area.
I can really feel this magnet pulling towards you.
Damn.
What does the archer have that I don't have?
Flavor.
What?
What is that?
Good flavor.
Vegetable.
I love vegetable.
I'm not gonna comment anymore.
Oh,
wait, what?
Wait, but, like, how do...
I'm so confused.
You have to wait until we're both ready.
We have to both do at the same time.
I literally just said that.
The artichoke said that.
Okay, go.
Yeah!
We did it!
Did you hear that?
I love artichoke.
You love it so much, why don't you marry it?
We should stay close to each other.
yeah keep your magnet ready what the fuck are you doing your
magnet i don't know let's move on whoa there's the tower ah
great oh i get up this hill what easy oh you have to grab
onto the side and then i grab onto you oh i'm grabbing onto
you i'm like on your fucking shoulder
Don't worry, I can grab onto this one.
I'm going to grab onto this one.
Follow me!
It'd be so funny if I let go right now.
Oh, man, I really want to eat my artichoke.
It'd be so funny.
All right, we got to go to the...
Oh, I think we can make it to the next blue.
I think we can make it.
We can't make it.
Gotta go to the red.
I got it.
Don't worry, I got you.
Why do you think you've caught me?
I'm making sure you don't fall.
In gumming gusks.
No, get this one!
Yes!
I got you!
Holy God, are you!
I'm making sure your boots are digging into the snow right
now.
Shut up.
What are you doing?
I can't hold the crowd.
The wind soar reaches here.
Alright, we're good.
The wind doesn't reach us here.
What are you doing?
What the fuck?
Does it not stop?
Oh, I don't think it stops.
I think we have to go to the right.
There's cover on the other side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to go.
I just hold on to you.
Yeah.
And then we do this.
All right.
I think we go here.
the longer we're here the longer we play this game listen
that's fine by me then i'll go backwards
i will go all the way down this mountain you think i won't
you think i won't go all the way down this I'll just because
I will.
I am that spiteful.
I'm also that spiteful.
Am I?
Is it?
Oh.
Swept away!
One last push
Where are you?
Where the fuck did you go?
Wait out Where the fuck did you go?
I'm losing
That's fucking right I didn't I need you.
I'm already at the next stage.
I wasn't going to work.
What the fuck?
Where even are you?
I'll wait.
Get over here!
Grip onto me!
Huh?
Oh my god.
How the fuck do I get to the other side?
Get over here!
Say something.
I'm losing grip!
I don't need you.
Yeah, you do it on your own.
Okay, okay, I need you.
I need you.
Get up.
I'm literally right next to you.
I can't even get up here.
You have to let go because I can't even get up here!
I can't use the magnet!
I don't know where to go from here.
Where do we go from here?
We just...
Oh!
Oh, it's a meat in the middle!
Okay, I'll go on the other side.
You stay there.
All right, here we go.
Are you ready?
Three, two, one, go.
We did it.
Through sheer determination.
Oh, we did it.
It says come.
This is a healthy marriage.
Look, you're supposed to come.
Look, look, look, look.
I'm not looking, I'm not looking.
I'm closing my eyes.
Look, look.
Disconnected.
Yes!
That was Kojima.
Yeah!
See, this is a healthy relationship.
I'll see marriage.
My turn to sit here.
I think we can finish the game.
No way.
There's no way.
I think we can finish the game.
Kumi, Kumi, there's two more chapters, Kumi.
Hello, Kazu.
Focus.
So pretty.
Oh, the Obororarealis.
Yeah.
At this time of day.
The Obororarealis.
Ah, yeah.
At this time of day.
At this hour.
Right in this very location.
The snow globe.
This is where I...
Wait, what was it again?
The what?
The Oborararealis.
Oh, my God.
Aurora?
Aurora.
The Oborarealis.
Really?
How you forgot your whole speech.
It was the worst proposal in the history.
Wait, I proposed to you here?
I thought you proposed here.
Yeah, I proposed here.
Look at the memories.
You hear about the words.
It was the way you handled it.
Without trying to hide how scared you were.
It was brave.
I'm a brave boy.
Mama said I'm a brave boy.
Why do you keep talking?
Eww!
Bro, he ruined the moment!
Making great progress!
He ruined the moment!
Are you ready?
Let's get going!
I hate seeing his disfigured tongue in his mouth.
Oh, is the lights working?
Wow!
Woo-wee!
The lights working again.
Shake it.
They're still inside.
Dad, Dad, look!
Look!
Look at the snow globe!
You hear the screams in the snow globe.
Why haven't I ever seen this picture before?
Look, Dad.
That's when Daddy and Mommy were last happy before I was
born.
They're mom and dad.
Yes, we're thrilled.
Now, how do you find your purpose in life?
Through, wait for it, passion.
Oh god.
We're gonna have sex.
What?
Because you lost your passion, Cody.
A passion that lights the past.
to your purpose in life.
Passion, path, purpose, passion, you know.
Uh, no.
Maybe he's talking about you wanting to be a gardener.
Yeah, it's about gardening.
God, goomy.
It's what's about gardening.
I'm gonna rake your garden.
What?
I never really think to appreciate what I did.
it's my fault you see this is why we can't live together you
see what does she say gotta spread those seeds
who said that zero risk come on even though i sold that from
chat
i have garden risk Oh my gosh, my god, I told you I'm going
to rake the garden, the actual garden.
Oh yeah, but everything still looks beautiful.
And, and all thanks to my painstaking groundwork, I might
add.
Oh, really?
Painstaking groundwork, huh?
Look at this.
Come on.
Cousin, did you want to- I didn't plant that.
What is it?
Yeah!
Use your head.
And you understand soon enough.
My head.
Whoa!
Ew!
What the fuck?
That's fucking gross.
This time you will encourage and support his passion.
No!
Support my passion!
Wait, what is that?
I think it's a weed killer.
Alright, are we calling here, right?
That was...
That purple thing is blocking our way.
We can finish this next week.
There's still three more chapters.
We need to get rid of it.
You know, I'm happy to end it here because I ended with my
nice guard and Riz.
Say uh.
What?
No!
Say uh!
Get away from me!
What the fuck is that?
No!
Stop!
What is that?
Say uh.
I don't want to.
Oh, GGs.
Oh my god.
GGs, man.
We'll finish this next week.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
What a journey.
I feel like I feel like I aged so much.
We have a very loving relationship.
I'm going to go.
Every second spent with you is like a miracle.
Why do you keep saying things?
What do you mean?
Why?
It's, I'm risen.
I'm risen.
Is it working?
is it working is it is it is it is it is it is it all right
gg scoomy are you gonna be taking a nap we're gonna play
play uh we're gonna play it tft i think i might log on
minecraft a little minecraft i see what's going on and then
tfp all right gg's goomy have fun crafting have fun maybe
i'll check it out all right i'll see you later then all
right i'll message you all right bye bye bye whoa whoa
you know you know it's love when your wife spits at you
all right i'll see you later Bye bye Bye bye Bye bye Oh my
god What a journey today, child What a fucking journey Three
more chapters left Oh I'm tired Oh yeah I know they were
Updates, updates, updates Apparently Challenger Circuit has
been Delayed, there was an update Regarding Challenger
Circuit So, most likely, I might take Saturday as a rest
day.
So, Saturday might be a rest day, then.
Because I decided to use it as a day to just rest up a
little bit and recoup some energy.
So, that's going to be delayed.
It's delayed to, like, April, I think.
April 6th, yeah.
It's going to be delayed to April 6th.
They're moving around the schedule to fit the other...
Uh, tournament that got delayed, so there's like a lot of
stuff that's being moved around, so that's why, that's why,
that shit is, that got moved.
Um, and, uh, what else?
What else?
Uh, next week, I know I said I wanted to play Dead Rising
next week to start Dead Rising playthrough, but then I
remember Dead Rising is Majority Escort missions, and then
like, I already went through a lot of escort missions with
Resident Evil.
So I decided that we're going to play a different game.
We're going to start a different game next week.
Because I want a little break from doing escort missions.
So those are the updates for today.
Are you going to call it here?
Because I do have a lot of behind the scenes to work on.
As well as preparing for tomorrow's stream.
So I, unfortunately, there will be no disaster not in the
chat reading.
But thank you all for coming.
I hope you guys enjoyed part two of It Takes Two.
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye